foreign
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed it is Trump
talking about massive dumps and by the
way extra points if you can sample Trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
dumps
[Music]
[Music]
multiple times
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just
dumps
big massive dumps dumps
[Music]
amounts of water where the water rushes
out to see
people with flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to Once dumps
[Music]
[Music]
what is going on here what is go what is
going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive ducks
cost of the election
what is going on here what is the what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here
yum yums
[Music]
dump
[Music]
big massive dumps
thank you
foreign
welcome everybody I am back and I am
back on Twitch it is a defiant and
principled return I will explain what's
going on we are now moving into closing
arguments and the trial for the killing
of Ahmad Arbury and it is something we
are looking into very very closely now
many of you wondering sir how are you
back on Twitch you were banned for 30
days and it's not been 30 days and of
course you would be right
I don't really have an answer for you
within hours of the end of The Written
House trial last week
I got a message from twitch saying
you've been unbanned
I I don't know what else to tell you
that's what it is all I can tell you is
I am so glad to be back on Twitch and
even though we had the Thousand paid
Subs when we were banned and we've lost
close to 200 of those we're back and
we're going to rebuild and we're gonna
put Brick by Brick back on the wall
that's what it's going to be so I
actually have a call in four minutes
we're going to be streaming this uh for
the duration of the day so I'm going to
step away and then I'm going to be back
I did want to let you guys know just one
thing
um I did yesterday
find some incredible mango prices under
the Biden regime four for five dollars
these are organic a dollar 25 a mango
which I think is absolutely incredible
I think this is absolutely incredible
and if you
I mean listen you know if you're blaming
Biden for the gas prices which I don't
think you should
then at least to some degree you've got
to thank Biden for this incredible mango
pricing and I grabbed a couple of them
and it really felt like Freedom when I
was when I was doing it so I really
really appreciate that and think it's an
absolutely tremendous thing we do have
um super Chats on the screen
Bay photo says sir did twitch adjudicate
with a giant toy hammer they didn't it
was just a very very brief message I'm
confused as to what even happened uh to
be totally um to be totally honest with
you but I'm glad to be back I can't
thank enough all the people that are
re-pledging and all of that stuff so
let's get right into this I'm going to
step away briefly I've got to take a
phone call in two minutes but we're
we're streaming we're live we're doing
it closing arguments very very important
stuff here electronic equipment stolen
from the offshore boat while it was
parked in the RV garage and Bob said
that's a burglary a burglary had been
committed in this residence and he said
that's right but it was never reported
like we didn't have a report about it so
I didn't really investigate it
that is a burglary and he has admitted
that to you as well
Mr Olson surveillance camera shows
that Mr Aubry walked into the
neighborhood
didn't run
he then stood in the yard
and put his hands on his hips
looked around like this
and then went into the residence
that Al benzi was doing work in his yard
and he saw this gentleman who resembled
the gentleman who had committed what
they thought was a burglary in that
residence
he shut down the work that he was doing
put a gun in his pocket grabbed his cell
phone and he walked all the way up to
the street to the corner
where Jones meets Satilla where he keeps
his mailbox
and he stood there
right next to this tree
and he called 9-1-1
at some point in the video
when you see Mr Aubry run out you'll see
he passes right through the window
and Mr albenzi is standing right there
on the phone calling the police
his behavior then changes instantly Mr
Aubry is at a full Sprint
running into the neighborhood
running into the neighborhood
the state is going to infer means he's
going on his regular job no because
running out of the neighborhood
is a problem
it's a problem now because there's a guy
standing there on the phone looking at
you
back in the same residence that you've
been caught in now three times
caught meaning off camera and police
coming and searching with lights
and Travis McMichael and to return to
that house in the middle of the day
like that after being run off
imagine going to visit a house under
normal circumstances oh this house looks
like one we might want to buy I'm going
to go in there then somebody comes up to
you with headlights and tries to stop
you from going into the house and
confronts you about it
are you literally ever going to go back
to that house again
it is unreasonable to think that he's
going back there for some lawful purpose
after being run out of there three times
before
so he doesn't run out of either of the
entrances
to go back across the street where he
lives he runs deep into the neighborhood
someone has called the police
now Travis
told you
nothing has erased from his mind about
this individual in the two weeks between
February 11th and February 23rd it's all
still there
and while he's sitting in his home his
dad comes running in the house and says
the guy who's been breaking in down the
street is back he's running past
get your gun
Travis and his dad carry their firearms
for protection wherever they go
they do
the law allows him to do it they have
permits to do it Travis testified he had
a concealed permit at one point the law
allows this Behavior
Travis comes out to the street he looks
down the street
right across here he is at 2 30. he
comes out here Mr Aubry has already run
past
he comes out here he looks down the
street
from where the house is and sees Mr Matt
and benzi
who is walking towards him and
eventually after a couple houses goes
like this
and points down the street
it is reasonable to conclude that based
on what his dad said who just came
running in the house the guy's back
who's broken in to come outside and look
and see and see Mr albenzi who he knows
who's he's talked with
these shared thoughts and feelings about
the person breaking in the house is now
saying go that way
the guy is back
to get in this car and go
you cannot act on the unsupported
statements
of others
the state has characterized that which
is an accurate statement of the law as
Travis's mom
are you kidding
after all that we have seen
after all that he has experienced after
all the conversation that he's had after
all the videos that he's seen after what
he him experienced himself
that he's just swung off of what his
mommy told him
this is what this is what the state
wants you to do something about
this is what they're trying to inject
into this case knowing despite that that
Travis has called the police on the
white man under the bridge
knowing that Travis called the police on
a carjacker or told his police friends
when he was in the Coast Guard and a
report was made about the white guy that
tried to Rob his truck
knowing that Travis called the police
about his gun being stolen and readily
admits I don't know who stole it
knowing that Travis called the police on
the 11th of February
they want to try to reduce this case
down to this statement which is
not true
Travis had all of this his reading
Facebook everything going on at Leary
english's house
knowing about what was happening in
Satilla Shores speaking with everybody
on the 11th his own experience albenzi
signaling officer rash and Matt Al benzi
this is what he carried with him when he
left his driveway that day
reasonable and probable grounds of
Suspicion reasonable and probable
grounds of Suspicion
facts and circumstances to warn a
prudent person one taking care to
understand the truth
in believing that the suspect has
committed the offense of burglary Travis
believes he's committed the offense of
unquote
the facts necessary to establish
probable cause for arrest are less than
those required to prove guilt Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt
it's more than suspicion or possibility
it's got to be a probability probably
and he said I had a probability there
was a probability that this was the guy
who did it and here's why I think he did
it and I wrote down every one of the
things that we talked about as he
testified
I wrote them all down and they are all
encapsulated in that slide I just told
you
this is where Duty and responsibility
and following the law
becomes intertwined with heartache and
tragedy
because you do have the right to
performances of the rest
you do have the right to have a firearm
when you make an arrest
you do have the right
to stop a person and to hold them and
detain them for the police
and there is risk with that
and there are tragic consequences that
can come from that and we can all sit
here right now and say what the state
has said from the very beginning and
what Travis himself recognizes
if he had only stayed home
that day
he just sat on the couch and fall asleep
with his kid that day
I was told just not a day that doesn't
go by but he doesn't think that exact
same thing
but the law allows the citizens to make
a citizen's arrest and if doing so
properly
it is the reason for the actions that
follow
here
you talk about an offense being
committed in his presence or when his
immediate knowledge what could be more
immediate than February 11th
what could be more immediate than seeing
the videos of him in the house and
talking with police officers and other
people including hearing from Larry
English through others that he actually
had stuff stolen from his problem and a
fence has been committed and he knows
about it
he's he's seen everything other than the
hand on
the equipment that was stolen
if it's a felony and the offender is
escaping or attempting to escape
then you can arrest them upon reasonable
and probable grounds of Suspicion
probable cause
Travis said many many times it was the
totality of the circumstances that's his
Coast Guard brain that's his Coast Guard
brain thing everything that I knew
gave me the belief that a crime had been
committed
Escape
private citizens warrant arrests must
occur immediately after the perpetration
of the offense
or
in the case of felonies during Escape
not every person is arrested at the
moment they commit a crime
not every person is arrested by police
because sometimes the police don't get
there in time but if they learn about
the person and they have information
about the person
Escape can happen anytime
this game can happen later
doesn't have to happen right at the same
time the crime is committed there's no
law that says that
there's no time limit imposed and police
would never be able to arrest anybody
and a citizen is in the same shoes as an
officer when it comes to citizens arrest
so
Travis leaving his house
decides he's going to follow
that's what he does
he pulls out after his dad crammed into
the front seat with the kids seat there
and he follows and he watches
and he pulls up next to this gentleman
no gun is raised no violence is ensued
he doesn't get out of the car he doesn't
tackle him he doesn't do anything he
does what a reasonably prudent person
would do he does what his training has
taught him to do to use leaps and he
says hey man what's going on can you
stop for a second please I want to talk
to you for a second
there is no violence
Travis wanted violence against this man
if Travis wanted to hurt him or commit
an aggravated assault or commit a false
imprisonment he could have done it right
then and there he doesn't he talks to
him
strawberry looks in the eyes doesn't say
a word doesn't have to but that's
information for Travis
is it so offensive to pull up next to
somebody and say hey man can you stop
for a second I want to talk to you it's
for making you hold on a second is that
so offensive
so
he stops he starts to go back one way
Travis backs up alongside of him three
feet away not pulling in front of him
not pulling behind him just tries to
talk to him Mr Aubry takes off running
down the street
and traps watches him
there he goes
doesn't take a gun out shoot him in the
back
then take a gun out and commit an
aggravated assault let him take a gun
and try to kill him doesn't try to hit
him with his truck he watches him
watching
so he pulls up next to him and he stops
again he says hey hey hold on a second I
just want to talk to you for a minute
something's going on back there we want
to know what's going on he's not saying
to the guy I don't know what's been
going on in this neighborhood to do that
would do what it would escalate the
situation so he just says we want to
know what's going on back there why is
that guy pointing at you
why is he why is he doing that
Mr he stops he looks so dead in the eyes
doesn't say a word and Travis just says
we want you to stay right here we're
calling the cops call the cops
call the cops
and Mr Aubrey Boltz
now on the subject of police Travis told
you
got in the car with my dad I said dad
are the cops coming yeah yeah go this
way go this way
it's very clear he says he asked his
father about the cops being called
not like it's a
a new thing for the McMichaels to call
the police
here when they say call the cops now he
bowls and it's on that bolting that
Travis thinks this guy knows he's caught
he knows he's called
because he's bolting he's looked at me
he won't talk to me that's odd I'm not
talking to him in a too aggressive of a
way and he bolts
and Travis stays right where he is
and he watches
and watches what happens between this
truck
he has no clue who this black truck is
in terms of evidence there is no
evidence of any communication between
these people any cooperation between no
help no assistant no encouraging nothing
so he sees this truck and he tells you
it's one of a couple things it's either
the guy from up at 220 or it's his buddy
maybe trying to give him a lift or now
that I'm watching him he's being very
aggressive against this truck
he's watching it from 200 feet away
but he's thinking this guy's being
really aggressive this is
something something off with this guy
his dad says Travis
go Dad gets out of the car climbs in the
back of the truck with his
rebuilt hip and his medical issues
Travis watched him get in looks down the
street sees this takes his gun off the
floorboard puts it up on the bench seat
his dad says go go get down the street
Travis says no
I'm not going back that way
something's off with this guy I'm not
going into that
well
if he wanted to go committed aggravated
assault if he wanted to go do a false
imprisonment if he wanted to end the
life of somebody whether it's murder or
felony murder
there's another chance
but he doesn't
just watch it
and then he says
I'm going to drive around
the judge is going to charge you on
hijacking motor vehicle a person commits
the crime of hijacking a motor vehicle
on the second degree when such person
obtains a motor vehicle from an
individual without his or her consent
Travis is watching this gentleman try to
get in the car in an aggressive way and
he thinks that does not look good
whether he thinks to himself that's a
hijacking or not
it doesn't look good
it looks dangerous
Travis also told you that when he came
face to face with this Aubry even though
he didn't speak he looked very angry he
looked very upset clinching his teeth
but not saying a word
these are the notes I took about it
right in front of you guys
wrote it down as he was talking stop
please stop mad clinched teeth it was
very unexpected what's going on I want
to talk to you what's going on police
are on the way and then his dad says go
back he says I am not going back there
I'll go from Beaufort around to homes
and that's what he does he drives around
now his dad's in the back of the truck
is that is old and firm
he's sitting on this
bench in the back of the truck Travis
says he's going with his foot on the
brake pretty much three or four miles an
hour drives all the way around thinking
I'm not going to go back into this mess
down here I'll drive around and when he
drives around you've now learned about
this dog leg that black line essentially
is the dog leg you can't see past it
Travis tells you the first thing he sees
is Mr Aubry doing a U-turn right there
at the crest of that turn
what does he do he watches does he drive
at him no does he try to tackle him no
does he put a shotgun at him no does he
yell at him no
he's trying to continue to assess the
situation in a reasonable prudent
fashion
then he drives across the dog leg comes
all the way to Industry and he sees
Mr Aubry again with this truck
again with this truck tangled up with
this truck
and what it looks like again aggression
at the truck so Travis stops
cops
he's thinking to himself
why is this guy not running
through this open yard this is Satilla
right here this is Holmes this is where
he sees the truck
what is with it that this guy's not
going this way and who is that truck
what's happening
instead they both run around Travis back
up around the gauntlet
Travis says okay I'm watching I'm
looking I'm going to pull forward stop
in my car at the end of the street and
I'm just going to take up a spot right
here I'm going to take up a spot here I
know that he's currently not over here I
know he's not behind me I can see my
house right there I can see up Satilla
drive and I'm looking up homes I'm just
going to take up residence right here
and I'm going to watch to see what
happens next
because maybe this guy will come back
and we can stop him or maybe he'll just
keep running that way maybe he'll keep
running that way and I can tell the
police I'm pretty sure he's not this way
pretty sure he's not over here he's not
there
he's headed that way
what he doesn't know is that Mr Aubry is
turning around up on the other side of
the dog leg and this is where our video
picks up with Roddy Pine
by now
it should be clear Travis doesn't even
know where Roddy Brian is to say that
Roddy Bryant's turn up there and and to
follow him back Travis has no idea
what's happening Behind The Blind Side
of that curve
and still doesn't know who this truck is
and why this gentleman is interacting
with it in the way that he is
but this is what's happening unbeknownst
to Travis Mr Aubry turns around and you
you get a quick glimpse of what's up the
street and it isn't Travis McMichael's
truck
it isn't there
it's because it's all the way back down
homes near Satilla
state
is going to play the recording that
you've heard of Mr Brian turning driving
and revving and doing all this stuff
this will be the third interaction that
Mr Aubry will have coming at this truck
and Mr Brian is freaked out to say the
least so freaked out he drops his phone
this is where the phone drops and goes
pitch black for about a minute
and in this time you'll hear sounds
you'll hear engine noise you'll hear
turning you'll hear shifting you'll hear
seat belts clanking you'll hear the
three-point turn eventually says well
you know what I'm going to head back
that way
but what you don't hear on that phone
even after audio enhancement
even after any kind of of um working
with audio Specialists and digital
Specialists you'll never ever hear any
yelling and no communication between
Travis or Greg the state wants you to
think that it's at this moment Greg
McMichael Drives By and says I'm going
to blow your GD head off
well if he said it you'd have heard it
you've been on that telephone and they
had a plate it for you
it ain't there
so
Roddy Brian is all the way up this blue
mailbox down here closer up pictures
where Mr Aubry turns around this is the
demonstration video with Seacrest and
this is Mr Brian's actual video This is
how far up the road he is
this is the the minute that he's been
with this phone down on the floor
and in this minute
two times Mr Aubry is going to run
towards Travis first time turn around
and go back
and the second time
he'll turn around and go back and that's
where that video will pick him up on the
second time
so the first time Ahmad Aubry comes
across that
dog leg he's coming at Travis
at this moment he's looking into
Travis's eyes and he's coming at him and
ultimately is is going to get within 10
feet of him running while Travis is
saying stop do not come any closer stop
right there stop
no gun in his hand
just saying stop do not come any closer
now at this moment Travis
has already had his experience obviously
where he reached for the gun before
he was acting bold he's not going to
forget that he's not going to forget
that he just saw what looked like
attacking this truck
acting violent being bold
and none of what what he experienced
that day will be forgotten trying to
talk to him we want to talk to you
what's going on we've called the police
and noting that he's not acting right
something is off and Dad's saying going
back there he said no way I'm not going
back to that
but now he's running at Travis we have
proof that he was on that truck because
his palm print is right there and it's
consistent with a right thumbprint right
there that's just one piece of proof
that his hands were on the door that
supports Travis's belief that he was
trying to get into that truck
and here he comes
and Travis finally takes a stand and
says do not come any closer to me
ultimately Travis when he gets about 10
feet reaches into the truck like this
and that's what causes Mr Arboretum
he runs all the way back
Travis testified I ran to him for about
10 yards
I don't know because my main concern is
this guy's got a gun I'm trying to avoid
the whole situation from happening
so he watches them
there's there's two options here
there's watching him
until the police arrive and giving
directions and there's also stopping
them
I'm um I'm seeing folks on Twitch ask uh
whether I'm autistic perfectly
reasonable question
um I'm I'm not
no big deal not not big emotionally
charged
wait where are the police
where are they they should be here by
now
that's what he says to his dad where the
heck are the places you did you call the
police no I don't have my cell phone on
me what
dad
yeah the house the number he gives it
listens gives it to him
again it's what it's what they do they
call the police
and now Mama's coming back for the
second time
Travis felt
and it was through Rehabilitation on
redirect examination that we learned
during his interview with Bill hilly he
was telling no hilly the same things
something not there he's not the stone
is not connecting it up
something's not right
I'm telling him to quit stop coming at
me I see where it's going the second
time around I see where this is going
and by the way he was acting prior to I
don't I don't know if he had a weapon on
him
an aggravated assault by the way is
a felony that can be committed by the
use of fists
of the use of a dangerous object or
weapon
threat of it
the intent to use your fist to create
serious bodily injury fists are that
weapon
and right now as Ahmad Aubry is running
toward Travis B Michael he could have a
gun and he definitely has fists and he's
coming straight at him after being told
the first time to stop and turn around
and didn't do it
until Travis had to reach inside his car
that has now put him on alert
the second time that Mr Arbury comes
down the street
Travis says he gets 30 to 40 feet from
him he's afraid that he will be on him
in a matter of seconds
he is afraid that he will beat him with
his fists or whatever weapon he might
have
and he's scared
and so he's done what he thinks the law
allows him to do which is to try to
de-escalate that approach by showing
Force
showing Force necessary to prevent
traffic this is the he was becoming
violent to prevent violence
and he does it to defend himself to
protect himself
they call it a 21-foot rule
so he was a little early he was at 30
for 40.
and he did it because he was afraid and
what happens is it causes a reaction
from a mod he changes from the left side
of the road to the right
but then he starts coming back at Travis
across the road again
and then gets even closer
he starts on the left it causes him to
change but then he comes back again once
the gun is down he comes back again
and changes to the left side of the road
and now we see him going back over
toward the right
now
Travis
this is his truck looking down on it
Travis is here
originally in the door jamb
but he told you as Mr Aubry came closer
he did this it made him change direction
now he's coming he's wavering on the
road and so Travis is walking away he's
backing up
he's not charging at him
he's backing up to try to create space
and distance he has this gun here and he
is literally watching him
see his foot
plant right there and Travis is thinking
to himself
please turn
please turn turn please turn
that's what he told y'all y'all what he
told no hilly please turn into this yard
please don't come at me I am backing up
I'm just trying to keep an eye to make
sure you please don't come at me
and as he comes around to the far side
of the truck he can't see him he's
backed up over here but so he's he's
stepped up over here to try to get a
look at what's happening because he's
afraid that Mr Aubry is going to be down
or finally go for the gun or seek cover
or something
please turn please turn
please go off into this yard
he never ever when he left his driveway
that day thought that things would end
this way
not ever
he told us I'm on the left side of my
truck I'm waiting for him to get by
he told us I'm going to interrupt
briefly I'm seeing a lot of the same
questions come up in the chat and want
to get caught up on everything I was
unbanned from twitch Friday within hours
of the end of the ritten house trial
with no explanation I don't know if it's
coincidence I just genuinely don't know
but what I can tell you is that I'm
really really really glad to be back we
were off to such a great start and on
that note I do want to say thanks to the
35 people that just grabbed twitch
subscriptions very very important to me
also want to say thanks to Tim light who
just signed up on my website at
joinpakman.com and his new member number
36 today
tonight oh uh the Andrew Yang interview
has been filmed and it will be published
tomorrow and it will be on tomorrow's
podcast very very interesting
conversation number two these are
closing arguments from the defense
um in the trial over the killing of
Ahmad Arbury we don't know exactly how
long this will go but we're covering it
then we will go into verdict watch and I
mean I don't we did it's just not clear
how long this is going to take this
makes extend beyond Thanksgiving we just
don't know yet
um tonight Kyle Rittenhouse will appear
as a hero on the Tucker Carlson program
for a full hour interview I believe it's
a full hour and I am going to be
covering it on tomorrow's program as
well uh maybe on the stream tomorrow
we've got your voicemails we have all
sorts of different things and let's
let's get back oh super chats and all of
it okay so let's let's get back to it
his head is down he's in full charge
first shot has already happened
you can see the same movement under the
truck
if you look here this is the shadow it's
kind of
eventually becomes kind of circular like
a stop sign yeah I don't know how you
argue self-defense when they jump in a
vehicle and Chase a mod arbory I I just
I just don't know
coming forward
coming all the way across
charging
with his feet Travis is trying to brace
himself
is there any question
that Ahmad already had his hands on this
firearm any question at all
Travis in his interview
told you
I was under shocked I was under stress I
I don't know if you had anything on the
gun I think he did I think he did I
think he had my shirt think he was
punching me
Travis is in a state of disrepair
there's no question
that ahmad's hands are on this gun and
the medical examiner from that stand
told you that if a mod Aubry is grabbing
this gun
and trying to pull it away that as the
gun gets pulled out of his hands and
fired
it could fire right on that wrist
and shoot into the chest and go across
the body
pull it straight out
no question
this is about this none
Travis turns into a mod trying to use
his entire body
pulls the end of the shotgun away from
him
gets pushed across the road into the
grass and the second shot goes off
here's the plume and it's believed that
it didn't hit Mr Harper
Travis coming out of the grass now
trying to yank this gun from Mr Arbury
again trying to yank it away from him
ahmad's hands still on it ahmad's fist
now raising is there any question that
Ahmad Aubry is assaulting Travis
McMichael right before that third shot
not one single bit of question
and that third shot goes off
and these two minutes end where they
started face to face looking into each
other's eyes never a word I don't
believe anybody's showing the slides
that's my understanding horrific and
tragic that this has happened
again
this is where the law
is
intertwined with
heartache and tragedy you are allowed to
defend yourself
you are allowed to use Force
that is likely
to cause death or serious bodily injury
if you believe it's necessary
at that moment Travis believed it was
necessary this is a law that is for a
person in Travis's situation
and you can do it to prevent death to
yourself or third person
or to prevent the commission of a
forcible felony
like aggravated assault aggravated
assault is a felony which can occur by
use of fists
Greg McMichael with a hip replacement
heart attack stroke
sitting in the back of that truck
Travis was afraid for him
so Greg is the dad who also participated
I guess they're making him out to be
just a basically a handicapped guy
couldn't couldn't have hurt anybody
this was really a case about that
Travis would not have reacted the way he
reacted
it was described to you
by Brooke Perez
he talked about how totally freaked out
he looked how totally discombobulated he
was
and she was right
the officer saying just just breathe
just breathe just take a minute just
breathe
calm down I know I know just hold on a
second
it was from that spot to this spot
within just an hour and a half of what
had happened
where he would be brought
for several hours of questioning he was
afraid he was in shock his adrenaline
was still going through his body
you guys know how fear and worry works
you sat here through jury selection all
day and probably felt that just by my
instinct is that regardless of the
verdict
these guys are not going to be lionized
like Rittenhouse you guys agree
even though
you too the judge
cloaks Travis in in sort of a shield of
Silence you don't have to testify you
are Presumed Innocent
you have the right to remain silent
the state has to prove that you did that
you don't have to get up there and
testify
I did because he wanted you to
understand what happened from him
he told you about the thefts and the
burglaries the totality of the facts why
he believed what he did that he wanted
to follow him that he wanted to talk to
him that he wanted to stop him for the
police to detain him don't be fooled by
this word arrest you don't have to
announce you're under arrest
told you why you raised the gun because
he was afraid that he would be on him
within seconds and the gun did exactly
what he hoped it would be it deterred
him
and why ultimately he shot
the state wants to criticize Travis for
testifying
I thought of this example as the state
was talking about bias and Prejudice
Travis is a liar he's a liar because he
has everything to gain by testifying
here he's got anything to lose by
testifying we are judgmental people
he's got two hours
to tell you what happened at the risk of
all of you sitting in Judgment of him
and saying I don't believe him he's got
everything to lose but should he be
labeled as so biased because the state
indicted him for murder and brought this
case to a trial where he has the right
to testify if he wants to should we
label him biased and motivated and a
liar because he took the stand
how about I say to any of you prove your
name
prove to me what your name is
I'm going to make up a name since we're
not naming you and we're not identifying
you my name is Patricia okay Patricia
prove your name is Patricia well okay uh
my mother I'll bring my mother into
court
what are we going to say about your
mother this is weird well of course she
wants to help you prove your name as
Patricia because she's your mother she
loves you she's on your side
so that's how that works well here's a
piece of paper that says my name is this
piece of mail that says my name is
Patricia
well of course you bring that document
but where'd that come from you could
have doctored that up
this kind of stuff while credibility is
for you to determine this whole assuming
that somebody is biased simply because
they elect to come and tell you what
happened
is a game
how is the Patricia example even
analogous to that what is this guy okay
I wanted to show you the law about
arrest and what it says that it doesn't
require you actually announcing that you
are under arrest it's doing any seizing
or taking or detaining either by
touching or by any act indicating an
intention
stop where you are stop right now and at
the last moment he said stop and get on
the ground
even along homes
or burfer stop stop let me talk to you
stop
trying to detain them
Travis could have
not gotten in this car
Travis could have told his dad this is
not going to work today dad you can't
say I'm a baby seat let's just go back
inside
Travis could have watched a mod run down
the road he could have done everything
other than what actually happened it
seems like it would have been smart and
wishes that he would have
but that does not mean that his actions
on that day were rooted in the law
that enabled him to go out there based
on everything he knew to do what he did
that day
Travis could have is another red herring
it's a flawed argument to take you off
and to make you feel emotional about
this case
that we would be here but four but four
but four
well of course that's true
but then we could go back and say
Travis wouldn't be here but for his
grandparents
picking his mother and father
but four is loose that is not what we're
talking about here we're talking about
strong cause dear God totality of
circumstances actual events
but for some loosey-goosey illegitimate
terms and the definition of probable
cause
Travis told you
understanding that what he could have
done differently that day would mean
that Ahmad Harvey was still alive he
told you I know that
it's a rehearsal I know that I killed
somebody and me
and him and our families we will never
be the same
and he carries that with him every day
the murder charge
along with the felony murder charge the
intentional acts is what those are
broken down to intentionally choosing to
commit a crime that either intends to
take a life of somebody or ultimately
takes the life of somebody
the only time in this case where life
was in danger was at the very end of
Holmes
when Mr Aubry chose to cut that turn and
go all the way across the front of that
truck every time they encounter each
other on this road three times in front
of Roddy Brian's house two times at the
end two times down here if he wanted to
kill him that's just a nonsensical
argument
this was not about taking someone's life
that day
foreign
mentioned to you in his opening
statement about Duty and responsibility
and I agree with that
Travis felt a duty and responsibility he
has felt it when he served the Coast
Guard he felt it to his community and he
felt it on this day and
February and he felt it during this
trial he took the stand and testify he
felt it was his duty and responsibility
to do that
state two has a duty and responsibility
they have a responsibility to be honest
with you to incorporate all of the facts
and take on their burden the state spent
two-thirds of their opening argument
saying what we were going to say
it was like two kids
in trouble and the first one that gets
to the parent says so and so did
something and
then we'll hold on a second let's hear
from the other child
they have a duty to you to prove under
the law that Travis at the time he
raised that gun was not in fear
that at the time so my my instinct so
far
is the judge here is way more competent
than in The Written House trial by the
way how are the calzones
the defense here is less competent than
in The Written House trial and the
prosecution is more competent than in
the ritten house trial
is every time you walk in your
neighborhood and somebody pulls up a
truck next to you and says hi or hey
they've committed an aggravated assault
or a false imprisonment
where's the evidence of that
the last Duty that is here is yours
and this is a very very tough one
you all understand and I will not be
labeled the links that we had gone to to
meet you
to understand who you are
to understand your background to
understand the thoughts that you have
about certain things to know whether we
want to strike you from the jury for
several hours to arrive at the point
where we felt in our hearts and our
minds that you all would carry the
banner of the duty and the
responsibility that is yours as jurors
this courtroom is sacred
it is our last place for truth it is
where we pull it from the witnesses if
we have to
and we present it to you
and we ask that you hold it dear
and that you accept your duty to not
erode the law as you sit here and think
about what the law allows a citizen to
do
it is going to take courage
it's going to take courage to set aside
what you think and feel
what may be trying to penetrate you from
other sources that you'd have tried to
do your best isn't it important what
they think like don't they need to put
aside what you think in case that have
been captured on photograph and on video
that have been testified to in this
courtroom it will take courage
and every count in this case you're
going to be asked to make a decision
about each
person accused Travis McMichael will
have his form
Greg McMichael Hills and Ronnie Bryan
his and you will be given the optional
every one of these charges
for not guilty or guilty
the evidence that's been demonstrated to
you there's reportedly four black
Pastors in the room and three white guys
dressed like Colonel Sanders
hardship on you
consequence for these families
I think the evidence is clear in this
case
Travis had spent
nine years in the Coast Guard search and
rescue policing the water sometimes 200
feet offshore going into situations that
were very difficult
working with law enforcement
reaching out and extending his hand as
firefighter law enforcement officer
combination
first time
in his life Travis is now in those
Waters
he is now the one who needs help
our goal here has been to do everything
we can
to dive into those Waters
to search for the truth
to pull it from the icy dips and to
raise it to the surface
and we have done that
we have done that with Travis McMichael
we have carried him to the surface to
you
and now the choice is yours
will you do as he has done in the past
to others will you reach out your hand
and extend it to Travis McMichael and
pull him out of those Waters
I think if you've heard anything that I
said
there's only one decision
he is not guilty on all charges
millabyte thank you all for your
attention wow
wow
thank you yeah we can just go ahead
foreign
thank you all right ladies and gentlemen
we are at a point we're going to break
for lunch we'll break for an hour it's
or just a little bit under well we're
going to reconvenience security again
until all of the closing arguments have
been made and you have received the
final charge of the court you are not to
discuss this case amongst yourselves
pizza is here with that instruction and
all of the other instructions I've given
you enjoy your lunch we'll see you back
here at 1 30. in fact uh we have Subway
tomorrow
warm food around new
foreign
all right so going to a lunch break we
do not know
um
this judge's preferences on food at this
time
um
we are looking at it
pretty strongly I would say Obama
[Music]
um
just making sure that this is the end
here before we jump in
all right we are in recess for lunch we
will reconvene at 1 30. thank you bye
all right and there it is
uh quite a day quite a day in the trial
over the killing of Ahmad Arbury all
right we're going to look at a bunch of
different things now and I'm so glad to
have the opportunity with everybody here
uh I do want to say thank you as we are
really trying to claw our way back into
the twitch game to the 11 additional
people who just grabbed twitch
subscriptions because we are back on
Twitch uh we are going to do website
members twitch and patreon let's see if
that will fit oh it doesn't quite fit oh
my God that's horrible
website members and twitch
there we go okay good so we've got that
um let me see
if we have everything else up and
running
we do okay so for everybody wondering
why I'm back on Twitch despite being
banned for 30 days as I mentioned
earlier I don't know within an hour or
so of The Written House trial ending a
twitch contacted me even though we were
only 11 hours 11 days into the 30-day
ban
and they um said I was unbanned which is
great I welcome that and I'm of course
really really glad to be back and I
guess I've learned my lesson I will be
much more careful when it comes to
showing uh violent elements of Court
exhibits I guess is what we're going to
have to do okay so we are back as far as
that goes let me get to the super chats
because I've fallen embarrassingly
behind Evan says David sir do you share
my respect for the judge's technical
food knowledge he obviously knows how
the pickles are inserted
right amazing how a ton of NRA money can
improve the quality of the defense
something is trying to penetrate them
wait what yeah it was a confusing
closing statement do you think the jury
will come to a conclusion today no I
don't believe so
did the defense admit to stacking the
jury well they all want to have jurors
they believe are advantageous to them
obviously
what is a loosey-goosey butt for a very
strange language
the defendant testified arbory was not a
threat to him yet the attorney is now
claiming self-defense gross it's been a
mess of a trial
sir have you seen the U.S has been added
to an annual list of backsliding
democracies from the first tank for the
first time I haven't seen that I'll look
into that
David would you consider adding Trump
said they took over the airports to your
sound board it cracks me up every time
I'm reminded he said that yeah we should
get that
hide this is the Chewbacca defense it
doesn't make sense
etc etc yeah
um a lot of things about this trial are
not making a lot of sense I would I
would completely agree with that
okay
um
so that's that I do want to announce
we're going to be doing our next viewer
Town Hall it's been scheduled for
December 14th at 6 PM eastern time I
want to make sure you guys are aware of
that like the last one it will be
streaming only on the second channel the
Pac-Man Live
second Channel I've been advised that
there's a really really funny video
of Tim pool appearing on the Alex Jones
program
and I guess it's crazy
um like super super cringe streamy let
me see if I can find it here
uh oh yeah here it is I do want to
briefly take a look at it with you guys
I haven't seen this yet let's see
surprise to who what does that even mean
a lot of folks are coming through
awesome this week it's great to have you
I really appreciate the great show you
do and I guess your libertarian Pro
Freedom Pro First Amendment operations
and how you've uh you know defended me
when I've been censored up front one of
the things that's really common when
Alex Jones has a guest on
that talks a lot is Jones starts to look
visibly bored no one else would so thank
you so much Tim and congratulations on
all your system you've been successful
I've known about you for over a decade
but you're really uh topping the charts
now so congratulations thanks uh
appreciate it man thanks for having me
it's great to have Tim Poole here in
studio with us uh again Tim you got
pretty excited earlier hearing about the
chef peso story yeah but I do want to
say one thing before we talk about this
because I heard I heard you mentioning
how you know I called you up and
everything well actually I was mini
golfing on this fine Sunday with my
girlfriend relaxing and you know oh is
this now does he mention his girlfriend
a lot now because remember there was
that thing where it sort of seemed like
maybe there were elements of incel going
on where he was saying like he doesn't
have a girlfriend because everybody else
has a problem or something like that is
this a thing now where he's regularly
dropping that in yeah you guys this
tonight we had a skeleton crew this
never happens
and we just had a lot of technical
problems is his mic working because
it is working can you hear it it is
working I don't hear him in my ear but
that's fine start over brother uh so
it's it's Sunday and I'm chilling I know
you're like hey would you come on the
Sunday show and I'm like look it's
Sunday very rarely get any time to do
anything and I was mini golfing with my
girlfriend but then I knew your second
girlfriend mentioned doing the show and
I was like I really do want to see you
know the show being done and then you
know I came over and then I'm like let's
just do it let's just do it and so so I
ended up coming up well I'm glad you're
here and it was you know we sometimes we
have a few hiccups we just rushed
somebody in that's what's great about
the way you do it with podcasting it's a
lot easier to do stuff than this big
giant fancy Studio I may just get rid of
all this and just go go kind of simple
like you guys are doing saying the
opposite I'm like man wow we we're down
here in Austin
um
what are all these papers what are all
these papers on Alex Jones does a bunch
of there's a ton of people down in
Austin who are good you know
commentators and and and and the life
that we want to have on the show so I
remember when I had when I had you on my
show the first time you asked me to come
on and I had this right action and I was
like I don't know people were saying it
was because I wouldn't go on your show
because it's you or something the
reality is I we couldn't travel
but we built an RV we got an RV and then
our CTO was able to put together a
mobile recording studio so now I can
come to Austin we're gonna do trips
we're gonna go like we needed to find a
way to actually travel and do more than
just one place but I'm Alex Jones looks
so bored already look at what we got and
it's like we got these little handycams
mounted to the wall and you got this
massive operation and I'm saying the
opposite I'm like man I got to build a
studio
this Bezos thing it's up on infowars.com
Amazon's Bezos predicts only limited
number of people will get to remain on
Earth it's going to be a park only for
the elites basically and then we're all
going to have to live in space I mean
any way you slice it this just gets more
and more authoritarian well so I was I
was listening and you know I'm hanging
out with my girlfriend I was like
the third mention of his girlfriend
um is there something weird about that
like I haven't watched this yet but the
first time he mentioned my girlfriend it
there was a weird tinge to it
we are um two minutes and 48 seconds in
he's he's mentioned the girlfriend three
times hold on who were you hanging out
with again
agree with him on that one because I'll
look at this quote it says millions of
people will move from Earth to space
over time and that's the vision of blue
origin millions of people working in
space so my question is
when you say it sounds like this
nefarious plot to like evict people from
Earth but I'm wondering if what he's
really saying is that people will choose
to leave and eventually no one wants to
be here so it'll just be like a
historical monument or something how is
it relevant that he was hanging out with
his girlfriend when he read this article
like how is how is that even related to
what you read the full transcripts and
actually watch what he said he says to
protect the Earth it's beautiful not
everyone just gets to be here uh we're
not going to just let people mess it up
or it's it's he he's saying he's going
to make you go to space and then if you
know everything else the globalists are
doing it's already in that whole
Direction but you're right if you read
that solely on your own and didn't know
the background of them you would uh you
know not understand that it's it's
basically the great reason now notice
that Alex Jones just told Tim Paul he
doesn't know what he's talking about but
he did it in a way that's you know no I
I agree with you I'm just playing you
know no it's good because I can't get
Mainline liberals on just like you can't
get them on your way
meant does he think Temple is liberal go
when I'm there and I wouldn't call you a
liberal just kind of classic American
Pro Freedom guy you've tried to get
liberals on uh so so I like people
challenging me it's crazy too I was
having a conversation with someone about
Lebanese tried didn't varsh go on
didn't Stephen Kenneth go on my
political positioning and it's crazy
that if you are for the truth if you are
russiagate complete and utter garbage
and if you from the beginning said it
was and I didn't your right wing and
then eventually when I came around now
I'm right wing and now he voted for
Trump
actually even even the way I was treated
by Google was as a left-wing commentator
so in other words it sounds like he's
saying others identified he was right
wing even when he still alleged to be
left-wing but he's like and eventually I
did come around so it seems like those
people were right I would read the news
about Russia gate I'd say oh the New
York Times is saying this is really
interesting let's let's give the
investigation a chance now that it's all
bunk and we know it's a bunk and I say
it's bunk and here's the evidence now
they're like that's right wing Kyle
writtenhouse is a really good example
from the beginning I had Witnesses on my
show we uh we had five different
Witnesses journalists with video anybody
know what he's talking about footage
giving us their account and I said
self-defense but the narrative from the
left was always that a white supremacist
traveled across eight lines with a gun
simply by being for the truth your right
wing or something so when it comes to
like actual politics I'm probably left
libertarian but there's a big difference
between the mainstream Progressive left
Libertarians they're really far left on
that far Alex Jones is so bored he's not
even paying attention
but they also just don't believe in the
truth that that's that that's it and
they and they play dirty games they
don't have integrity a green New Deal
you know when the green New Deal comes
out I was actually excited like hey look
a government infrastructure project to
make energy Independence in America and
develop new technologies we're working
on Fusion nuclear energy is great and
then what was the green New Deal Social
Equity social justice free college free
health care and I
it's in windmills that don't really are
it's just lying it's just it's just it's
just lying so I can sit here and be like
um decentralized networks I believe you
know we're working on building we have a
non-profit we've started recently where
we're building technology to give away
for free it's a very like left
libertarian perspective but we'll all
like me Ian the rest of the crew will be
called right wing simply for telling the
truth
absolutely uh where do you see not just
America but the world's going because
you had a they called it a rant but it
really wasn't uh well on your show just
a few days ago where now it's coming out
the New York Times not only are they
writing journalists now and going after
sources which is totally legal and
dangerous but now they're actually uh
leaking the information of the press so
I would say a reasonable person would
conclude if project Veritas James
O'Keefe and his staff his journalists
get raided by the FBI and within like an
hour I think the New York Times was
calling them saying what happened there
is either a snitch or at that point you
could be like someone in the FBI tipped
off the New York Times seems to be more
likely considering the speed then we get
project veritas's devices seized from
James O'Keefe himself they're going
through his devices we know they are
because a Court ruled had to stop
then those documents get leaked to the
New York Times so I try to be careful
um when I when I had this rant we're in
the middle of the show and you know
Luke's on the show and he says hey we're
getting word that the FBI is leaking
project Fair test is privileged legal
Communications to the New York Times and
so I pull up the tweets from trusted
sources and right off the bat I just I
assumed it was definitive and so this is
this is like just fodder for
like conspiracists I don't even it's
just the the entire language that's used
to describe everything I'll be a little
bit more careful and say it appears to
be by Beyond a reasonable that the FBI
did this
I just snapped when you have the federal
government rating a news organization a
journalistic Enterprise a non-profit no
less and then giving privileged
Communications to a company that they're
suing they're in a loss all right let's
like skip ahead to some other random
moment just we'll watch like one more
minute
we we do have the the the main risk of
you know YouTube being a large source of
where we we present our show and
everything and then we started uh
timcast.com to do members only segments
that's the show where you know we did we
did our two hour show with Steve Bannon
we talked a lot a lot about a lot of
things we didn't talk about election
stuff because that's where YouTube
outright ban you so as soon as we start
the members only show I literally said
did Donald Trump win the election let's
talk about voter fraud and this is the
challenge for us I mean I might be I may
be getting a lot of views now we may be
growing but they're not going to let me
get that big they're gonna they're gonna
figure out a way to Shadow band or tail
they've been doing it notifications
don't go off with for our show so we've
been we've been trying to diversify
build culture set up a website
notification as far I mean as far as I
know YouTube turned on off live
notifications like everybody in my
audience on YouTube stopped getting the
live notification emails and when I
asked our YouTube rep about it he was
like yeah YouTube got rid of that
feature
but I guess I should be ranting about it
it seems there's clicks to be had by
ranting about it you know I I I'll say
this our key demo we we MSNBC CNN ain't
got nothing on us our our key
demographic like 90 of the viewers we
get are young people they're they're
Millennials they're like 18 to 35 sure
and I knew that but I'm saying it's also
cool that like like if you've got
absolutely absolutely I'm I'm not
discounting that at all I'm just saying
man what a boring it's like the
conversation is not really going
anywhere it's very very strange all
right so there was that
um just all kind of uh kind of kind of
strange
um okay let me
um
oh we've got to ban people just as a
reminder we are back on Twitch but if
you come in here and just start putting
let's go Brandon in all caps you do get
instaband that applies on Twitch and it
applies on YouTube it's just annoying
it's just it's just a distraction we
don't like it we're not gonna do it okay
so you're gonna get banned uh one user
just got actually banned what I should
look at
is whether there are unbanned requests
on Twitch because we've been banned for
so long I do want to take a look at that
real quick
there might not be because you can't oh
there are okay hold on a second
let's take a look at some unbanned
requests
let's see
um user zolt hand said Biden only Lies
when he can actually speak Biden has
dementia they were banned
uh and then their unbanned request is so
much for free speech that's a that's a
perma-ban it's not really an argument uh
let's go Brandon
and they said sorry I was just memeing
okay I will unban assuming that you were
joking and you didn't realize that but
you'll be banned again majorly based
came in and said dumps in Biden's pants
um
okay I'll
I'll unban this one
uh user Byler man came in and said
wonder what Brandon thinks about this
case
free Kyle liberals make me sick
they say they're just joking around
all right I guess I'll unband I mean I
don't know maybe some people were
confused
um
all right and here's one other this one
I don't even think all right these these
on bands are I'm actually unbanning
people pretty quickly we're freeing a
lot of these people some of them seem to
have been caught up in the emotion of
the um
writtenhouse trial and did not seem to
be deliberately trolling so I'm being
sort of nice today to some degree uh
uh yeah there we go okay so we got that
let me get back to some super chats
um
come on David we've all been young and
in love oh wait Tim Poole is in his 30s
by the way my girlfriend and I sleep in
the same bed yeah thanks for mentioning
that
David all those paper papers on the desk
are the 11 780 votes that Trump needed
let me see if I have that
no I don't I don't have that
um Alex looks like he can only hear his
own heartbeat Happy Thanksgiving week
I'm spending money with my girlfriend
thanks for letting me know what are the
documents on the Alex Jones desk
what are the chances chances the Kenosha
Wisconsin parade attack and writtenhouse
verdict are connected so what I've heard
about the Wisconsin parade attack where
someone drove through a crowd with a car
what I read was that it was someone
escaping after some kind of a knife
attack and I don't know if the driver
was the perpetrator or the victim that's
the first thing I heard
[Music]
um
but I don't know
I don't know that we know that for sure
yet yeah there's no evidence that it's
connected exactly no evidence that's
been connected I do want to say thank
you to the 10 additional people that
just grabbed twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 57. I did want to work
with you guys to create a new coupon
code on the website now that the
um trial is over I think we're sort of
done with uncharged pickles let's take a
break lunch is here yeah
um so I want to create a new coupon code
with you guys any ideas what it should
be
hot food yeah I don't know about that
let me see here
coupons
we're going to create a new coupon oh we
haven't done Obama for yeah let's do
Obama I like that idea
that's a new one let's do add new let's
see who first person to use this gets a
free item from my online store
Obama let's make it a healthy discount
let's make it a healthy discount
and here we go I'm about to press the
button the new coupon code
is going to be obamna
very important code Obama
Obama
and
here we go
timpool's girlfriend would be an
interesting one too yeah okay coupon new
coupon code is obamna let's say to save
bigly
there we go
um or maybe just to save massive
there we go all right good first person
to use that code does get a free item
from my website let me get into a few uh
voicemails I did I we are so behind we
had we had managed to work our
voicemails down to 260 unreadable
unlistened to voicemails it's back up to
close to 600. let's just listen to a few
of these okay
hello David Bitcoin is classing again
are you gonna do a shell on bitcoin
going down like you do a show up they're
calling you up
David are you because Bitcoin I mean
bitty bitty Bitcoin bitty bitty Bim bong
is it anti-semitic to start doing
um
a song from Fiddler on the Roof and
using this voice is would we consider
this anti-Semitic
it's very embarrassing but is it
anti-semitic I guess is the question
twitch believes it is
uh YouTube
does not think it's oh YouTube also
thinks it's answered YouTube is less
sure twitch is pretty confident that
that's anti-semitic whereas YouTube is
sort of mixed okay let's
um let's hear from uh Whitney let's see
if she had a good weekend
um I woke up this morning
um for America
so it's really donate your money on the
apparently like the cars didn't go
through because there were like charges
to my account man I don't know what
Whitney's talking about
I just I just don't know
um Eric from I think this is Eric from
Mass
hey Dave how's it going my name is Tyler
adolpho oh it's not it's not this is so
this is a different person okay I'm a
republican I'm also a big fan of your
show and let's get right to the point I
am extremely worried about 2022 and I
would say for a lot of the same reasons
that you probably are that's going to
start off with I'm a republican I share
a lot of the same views as Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren and why are
you a Republican
doesn't really make sense
that's very confusing after discussion
for another time
but I feel like it's kind of the key
thing actually
I agree a lot Republican likes Bernie
and Warren and is worried like me about
2022.
doesn't sound like much of a Republican
the country's kind of like headed in
this direction and I don't want to use
like divisive terminology like left
right because me personally I like to
decide things on more of an issue by
issue basis which I guess is
contradictory I started off by saying
I'm a republican but not in like the
divisive kind of rhetoric that you see
you know the former occupant of the
White House use I'm a republic in the
sense that I believe that the government
should be involved in certain things
like that Constitution is very specific
about that uh government should not be
telling women what to do with their
bodies okay so on that issue you agree
with the left
um also someone that believes that
government has an obligation to promote
the general welfare of the public
okay so you're with the left on that and
I'll like use one last element of what I
do it's on that but like my big concern
is is that this new movement that's been
created um within the Republican party
is extremely dangerous and but it's not
just unique to the right wing so like
the big issue that I have when I try to
talk about it from the other side is
like I get it one side is absolutely out
of its mind um the right beliefs not all
of them but many in that part are
literally making the argument that you
know Democrats eat babies
okay so he's a Republican
agrees with Bernie and Warren
doesn't believe the government should
have a say in abortion believes the
government should be providing a basic
level of welfare
thinks the right is unhinged with some
of their bullet points
in what way are you a Republican
most but it's a significant amount
significant enough to where it's part of
a dialogue like and it's scary because
how do you reason with somebody who
thinks that Democrats eat babies
um and like this was an argument
actually felt articulated by Bill Maher
the other day and that was the
inspiration for why I'm calling in and
I'm not someone who would use this Omar
on a lot of things all right we're going
to move on it's very very interesting
um let's see here is Eric from Mass
hey David it's over from Mass I don't
think I've ever asked you this but uh
kind of important
and let's say you don't fully hate
America why do you hate about 65 of
America
just wondering if you could address that
uh oh it's not 65 I think I think
probably
um I mean listen I go with the Seinfeld
um perspective that probably
four to six percent
of people are like dateable I would say
um I think it's not that I hate 65 of
America but I do believe that there is a
Pareto
um
there's a Pareto distribution
um of incompetence which would sort of
put 80 of the country as incompetent
actually it's not even 65 Eric
but I don't hate him hi David
um so I thought the results of the Kyle
written book uh brittenberg okay all
right well it's Rittenberg come on guys
come on please
uh
uh okay I think we do have something
from Troy York as well
or maybe not no I guess I don't have
anything from Troy York right now okay
we'll get we'll get back to that I do
want to say thank you to Obama the first
person to sign up today using the coupon
code Obama Obama and new member number
58 if you're just joining us we have a
new coupon code right above my head it
is obamna The Written House trial is
over so the coupon code uncharged
pickles is done uh thanks to being the
first person to use the code Obama which
if that's not a real person I don't know
Obama has won a free item from the David
packman show store you gotta email info
davidpackman.com to take advantage of it
but you know we'll have to figure that
out I also want to say thanks to Kevin
gouldy and Amy Heidel who have signed up
using the code Obama Obama on my website
and I can't tell you how much I
appreciate that
also over on Twitch I want to say thank
you to sib jenke for signing up via
twitch Prime we are out of twitch jail
and you are a new member number 61 today
okay good let me uh let's go over a
couple other things while we have a
moment we're standing by here there they
are on lunch here at the um trial over
the killing of Ahmad Arbury they're
about to turn this over to the uh jury
if you've been watching it's going to be
very very soon they're just having lunch
right now
warm food around noon exactly so we have
a few minutes to look at a couple things
there's another really great clip
of another Fox News host being
confronted over the um
vaccine oh wait this isn't it well
that's not it
this is something else
uh
here it is okay check this out Pete
hegseth is one of these Fox News clowns
and he's been going crazy attacking the
Biden vaccine Mandate of course Fox News
has an even stricter one he was
confronted on it by Aiden McLaughlin
from mediaite he just started attacking
Aiden take a look at this it was a
vaccine or test requirement at the
Patriot Awards which is very similar to
the policy at Fox News do you have an
issue with Fox News having a policy like
that which is effectively the same as
Biden's vaccine mandate for big
businesses uh I uh
you know you're not mandated to get
vaccine because you can get a test I got
in charge of it just like with how Joe
Biden remember it's the same thing with
Biden
the same thing
uh I don't make the calls but either you
you have the option to get a test so
you're not it's not actually a complete
vaccine mandate just like with Joe Biden
yep got go on and that's fine I mean so
it's not my call so I'm grateful for the
people that provide us this opportunity
and and um the show went off without a
hitch right but it's just that you know
Joe Biden's vaccine mandate for big
businesses has been the subject of
criticism and that's even less stringent
than the one at Fox News right it
requires weekly testing as opposed to
daily testing so I'm curious as to why
you have an issue with the Joe Biden
vaccine mandate but no problem with the
one at Fox News
what do you want me to say
well maybe answer the question and
explain why you're a hypocrite hypocrite
clown
right I mean what do you mean what do
you want me to say it's called it's an
interview
you know how media works right Pete I
you're interviewed
I mean
ultimately uh
companies have prerogatives what the
government shouldn't be doing is telling
them what to do the government shouldn't
be telling them what to do every company
has its own policies and I'm beyond
grateful for the opportunity to work at
Fox News Channel and it does things that
no other organization does including
your organization that's true Fox is
definitely doing things that no other
New Media organization does that's
absolutely true EDI which is part of the
trash heap of left-week media that you
know does the same thing everyone else
does that's why we're number one I mean
I I can't even imagine what the clicks
are on your site
so this is what's called ad hominem now
he's just attacking the interviewer is
it like 15 people a day like only
journalists in New York City they click
on your that click 16. good they're the
only people that read mediaites people
read read the Fox News Channel so you
guys want to nitpick and do your thing
it's cool but uh I I could not be more
grateful for the Fox News channel
anybody understanding the explanation
there
I guess ultimately it's it's fine
if a business does it
but it's not okay if
the government requests it or puts it in
place I guess I don't know it's all very
very weird I want to say thank you to
Margaret oh there is no way I'm going to
be able to pronounce this
Margaret zent Georgie
is that I hope Margaret that that's okay
Margaret zent Georgie has just signed up
on my website with the coupon code Obama
Obama and his new member number 62 today
thank you so much Margaret
um we're gonna have a clip out later on
this very strange interview actually
it's even funnier
um so Donald Trump was interviewed by uh
Mark Levin about his book
now
it's literally a picture book okay Trump
wrote a book
but it's just a picture book look at
this
okay here's one of the pictures in the
book and look at the caption
attempting to Listen to Crazy Nancy
Pelosi in the Oval Office such natural
disagreement
it's literally a picture book this is
the staged Situation Room picture that
we now know was totally fake
fake and phony
so this book that he wrote it's
literally a picture book
um he was interviewed by Mark Levin
last night about the book
and
um
the interview is crazy here he talks
about gas prices
uh gasoline was 1.87 cents that was a
year ago now that's not true
a year ago gasoline was two dollars and
20 cents so that's lie number one
and now it's I guess just hit seven
dollars and fifty cents in California
now in California
maybe there's a place where super
premium is 750. I don't know
but
Trump said gas was a dollar eighty seven
a year ago it was 220. it's now 338
nationally
so you can't compare
gas nationally to gas in California
right
gas is 338 right now
and gases 470 in California it's not
750. so I guess that that's three lies
in 12 seconds is that is that about
right
three lies in 12 seconds
uh here's Trump talking about how it was
beautiful when he was President we
weren't leaving 85 billion dollars
behind we weren't leaving 10 cents
Beyond I said every bolt every screw
every nail
comes out and all of these things it was
a a beautiful period I was under assault
uh like no president has ever been I
assume I don't think any president has
ever been under assault like this
and one thing after another phony
impeachments
uh I call it the impeachment hoax number
one the impeachment hoax number two I
thought he was under paprika not under
salt ooh the the Mueller thing although
it worked out good but it took two and a
half years and it made it very difficult
to deal with certain countries in
particular Russia you know we could have
done some great things with Russia very
good for our country for our country
also good for Russia supposedly Old Bay
Seasoning has him under a barrel okay
then he talks about the whole Kim
Jong-un thing up in a war that's the
biggest problem we had so I became you
know we did very well with Kim Jong-un
and we liked each other isn't that a
terrible thing to say we like to I'll
get criticized oh he likes Kim Jong-un
well and what happened if you watched
the election I was called by the biggest
people big massive dumps
that's what we have and I did I got
along with him great he got along with
me great after a very rough start
if you remember Little Rocket Man
remember when he said they wrote each
other love letters and that they fell in
love Trump's still calling it the
Spanish Flu of 1917 and still wrongly
saying that it ended World War one let's
see if we can count the lies here all
over the world let me see so in 1917 as
you know we had okay there's lie number
one okay it was 1918 not 1917. that's
lie number one Spanish Flu it was called
and it possibly killed as many as a
hundred million people you know I don't
know if you read the history of the
Spanish flu but you probably I think you
read about everything but but it
probably was a thing that was most
responsible for ending World War one now
that's a lie the Spanish Flu did not end
World War One also when Trump says a
hundred million people killed the the
estimates are 17 to 50 million with a
sort of outside estimate maybe of a
hundred million
um it's not a lie it's not the
conventionally accepted number because
all the soldiers were sick
and many were dying the Spanish Flu was
devastating and they say up to a hundred
million people died
and it probably did end World War one
but a hundred million people I think
this would have been similar without the
vaccine now what's funny is if you want
to talk about the United States the
belief is that 675
000 people died of the Spanish Flu in
the U.S
and we're already at 800 000 from covet
so when Trump says it could have been it
could have been worse it is worse
it is worse because the number in the
U.S is higher you know whether it's 50
or 100 million okay then Trump says the
country's not living up to the
Constitution the number one I love our
country and our country is based on the
Constitution and you know our country is
not living up to the Constitution right
now with the kind of things you see it's
uh they're trying to subvert it now I
would like and I have a longer
commentary on this that we're going to
publish later
I first of all Mark Levin should be
saying uh sir why did you write a
picture book sir your wife is up in the
air right like that would be question
number one if this was a real interview
but the second question would be
what element
of the Constitution or the Bill of
Rights is being subverted right now
like actually ask what it is he would
probably say freedom of the press
because he mentions it but he wouldn't
really be able to defend it
and more so now than anybody would ever
believe Burley Bernie Sanders is saying
I can't believe they're doing this this
is far more than what they're doing to
our country
is perhaps you know they talk socialism
this is communism in so many ways what
is communism would be a great question
here
uh there's no freedom of the press the
Press there is freedom of the press this
is totally corrupt the press and them
are the same there's no freedom of the
press That's How communism starts it's
funny how he says the press and the
government are the same
when did that start because wouldn't
that have been the same not much has
changed with the media since he left
office it's all very very confused
um Trump says he did a great job with
covid but I built him a hospital I sent
in the hospital ship I built hospitals
in Louisiana I built hospitals all over
all over
portable hospitals thousands of beds we
did a phenomenal job except when it came
to public relations because no matter
what we did the Press would not cover it
fairly so we did a fantastic job the one
thing we are but I built all right
Jimmy Carter is happy because he's no
longer the worst president
that's unironic that that's like he's
being he's not being ironic but there's
a way in which it's actually funny
and the good news is Jimmy Carter is a
very happy man
because he's no longer going down as the
worst president in history
now you could say
thanks to Donald right but of course
that's not that's not what he means but
it's still pretty funny and here he is
being interviewed about his picture book
uh to check this out anyway yeah at a
meeting fill with individuals
what was that all about
well I have a number of pictures and I
have a picture of Nancy Pelosi guys the
book has a number of pictures okay I
have a picture of uh of uh Merkel of
Germany who I got along with very well
that was a pointer also we have a lot of
pointers you know there are a lot of
people pointing
but with Pelosi
yeah it isn't that great
and then lastly here's just a really
confused comment about gas prices this
is maybe my favorite moment from the
interview
um I don't think people see it that way
they knew that they got gasoline for X
dollars a tank and now they can multiply
times four and they're saying what's
happened
X dollars per tank okay hold on I'm
going back to act to uh to algebra
x per tank all multiplied times four
do I need a protractor or one of those
ti-83s for that I don't know
uh okay so that's that
um I want to see the SNL judge cold open
people they're telling me about that
um
where was it
where can I find anybody know where I
can find that
the cold open with someone playing the
judge
Judge Jeanine
is this the one it's this one oh okay
all right let's check it out
unavailable there's copyright
unavailable oh that's too bad
okay hold on let's get it let's get it
properly going here
good evening I'm judge Janine perro and
if anyone watching is wearing a hearing
aid sorry you're dead now
top story Kyle Rittenhouse was acquitted
of all charges that lovable Scamp was
put through a nightmare of a trial just
for doing the bravest thing any American
can do protecting an empty-use car lot
and someone else's Town go on to our
first guest he's as impartial as a dance
mom clapping harder than anyone please
welcome judge Bruce stroke oh thank you
thank you it's a pleasure to be here
with a fellow judge oh well thank you
for acknowledging my expertise you may
remember that I was in charge of
investigating Robert Durst for murder
back in 83. well folks 30 years and one
additional murder later we got him
now if I may say judge to judge what
turn me on this isn't great so far
that's why I ordered that the
prosecution not used the word victims
they were rioters and they weren't shot
they were gedoinked
but that did not give my client an
unfair advantage in any way you said my
client do you mean the defendant
oh oh yeah sure hey keep doing that well
you do you okay that's a little funny
but it's pretty cringy
judging
predictably the loony liberal outrage
machines in overdrive and you know how
much we love liberal tears around here
so I so I decided to invite two of them
here tonight oof I don't know about this
uh
yeah I don't know I guess the Trump
impersonator comes in at one point let's
see if that's any better best People's
sexiest man alive president Donald J
Trump well thank you very much Jenny
it's wonderful to be here this guy
actually is funny this guy is very good
you have a lot of thoughts on the
infrastructure bill so if it's okay I'm
just gonna let you riff while I sit here
and get absolutely rock hard
well you know I'm glad you brought up
that terrible bill because the truth is
nobody did more for infrastructure than
me and meeple I say and you know what
meeple of course are people who are me
saying I built it back even you know
what I think even a little bit better
because I did well okay big beautiful
wall
this guy is good this is actually very
good because
it goes into a grassy field okay frankly
that's Road
and if you take wall and lay it across
the river frankly Genie we're doing
Bridge
you know what can I get 60 seconds on
the clock please because this bill is
you know what sleepy Joe Biden is such a
disaster we're coming back we're coming
back in 2024 we're doing the reboot okay
everyone loves reboots people love to
avoid they're gonna like it again okay
just like iCarly just like iCarly
uh not only boots are good okay Joe
Biden tried to reboot Obama and it
flopped okay it flopped really bad just
like the female Ghostbusters
girl okay why did that why did they
reboot Gossip Girl why the hell you
simply can't match you cannot match the
electricity of Chuck Bass and Blair
Waldorf
you know there were dogs where Blair was
a bad friend to Serena and sometimes you
know what this was true sometimes Serena
was the bad friend to Blair
oh oh I hope I hope this never ends uh
can I get 60 more seconds said you know
what why don't we try a word search this
time can we make it word search I love
it if it was word search and you know
what
I was treated very unverely by Chris
Christie he was very nasty and he said
very nasty things about it
you know what boy Chris I mean we love
him he's a wonderful person but you know
what we don't like him very much I think
we hate him and you know what poor Chris
wasn't even the main interview he had to
sit on the battle with all the other
dopes and watch Bill do the new rules
and you know what speaking of new rules
Dua Lipa is one of our best songs
and frankly in terms of singer you can't
do better the Dua Lipa but you know what
her husband who is not very attractive
you know what it's terrible what they're
doing with Dua lipa's husband not being
attractive we have to do something about
it she's tall she's Albanian which is
basically White
you know who else is white Bob the
Builder build the wall Trump 2024.
[Applause]
oh man that's really pretty good I like
that
that's good that guy's that guys that
guy's good
I guess the actor is only like 30 or
something which is it which is extra
funny if you can believe that all right
welcome everybody I'm so glad that
you're here we are Live on YouTube
we are live on Facebook
and we are live on Twitch where I have
been unbanned and we are extremely
powerfully back I want to say thanks to
everybody who has been re-upping their
twitch Prime subscriptions please make
sure to check while we were suspended if
your membership uh your sub was
scheduled to renew it did not
and you have to do it manually so that's
a very very important thing okay let me
get to some other super chats premium is
close to four bucks a gallon in Seattle
all right
I guess that's the only new super chat
okay very good let's get to some other
voicemails oh and oh by the way if
you're just joining us we have a new
coupon code and the code is Obama Obama
and it must be spelled correctly at
joinpakman.com everybody who signs up
there gets a thank you from me or
someone else I guess someone else could
thank you I don't know
um okay let's get to some voicemails
here is one hot off the presses from
Whitney
okay
so in my defense it sounds like the
stream is playing in the background I
comes to people who like didn't grow up
like
yeah I just heard myself saying Spanish
Flu in the background here's another one
from Whitney
so like with my family
um like after the Holocaust like there
was like a certain amount of funds
um you know that were you know my
family's responsibility to receive and
then
um you know because of politics and
because things weren't going their way
um you know they had to put a fair
substantial amount of money into
politics to turn the world into
something else cheers uh okay a couple
from Jimmy from Philly
David kill me for silly White
Destiny has you by the balls pal you
can't even explain your way out of it do
you know how stupid you sound here oh my
God it's a hard bastard whoa very very
aggressive from Jimmy from Philly
calling right back in with another
devastating shot of these are body shots
baby give me some silly what
I am astounding
you have admitted that you were wrong by
the way I I there seemed to be a lot of
people
over on the destiny.gg subreddit element
who think that when I said in the middle
of the quote debate
you know what Stephen I think you're
right you convinced me there's people
who thought I was being serious when I
said that which really makes me
concerned that I am not communicating
effectively because it could not have
been more obvious satire let's continue
I mean
this is a moment
that will live
and Anthony
are you kidding me
kissing me you've been involved been
wrong your entire life
that would be better but this is a start
okay
um one other thing that you guys might
find funny
and if you don't find funny we'll get
away from this Jimmy called into some
kind of drug show
and he sent it to me here he is talking
to a drug guy
foreign
so let's see we've got Jimmy from Philly
let's bring
Europe
um
and back to speak
either Jimmy
how you doing I'm doing all right Jimmy
how are you
I'm going naturally man
good got to it mate
so uh
I've been doing two to four hundred
micrograms of LSD for the last two and a
half years every Saturday night oh wow
okay
even the drug guy is shocked by what
Jimmy is doing
that would be heavy use I guess yeah
but I don't know that
I know a lot of people say that it
teaches them something about themselves
and I don't know that I would say that
but two things I can definitely say are
much happier and a way more creative
there's no doubt about it the
creativity's through the roof I like to
make people laugh
and uh I always wanted to start a
YouTube channel right but you know I was
just like like what am I going to talk
about I mean now you can't shut me up
but hey I was going through all this
[ __ ] and then one day on a trip I
was like you know what [ __ ] it just do
it and I did it
I just did it and I don't know
technology I'm a boomer I'm like 58 like
discord's driving me crazy trying to get
a whole year you know but I'm but I'm
doing it you know and I'm tickled pink
and I'm really really happy about this
[ __ ] and LSD definitely had something to
do with it I mean there's no doubt about
it it's just just stood there you know I
would agree especially on the creativity
part I think I mean I I think that's a
kind of a universal thing that comes out
is this guy Scottish is that the accent
here these things is not they stimulate
uh creativity I think this stimulates a
desire to connect with Irish is this guy
Irish with other people and sure things
like expensive stories and sure is this
guy British uh like you know should yes
like say creativity
and you know I seem to be how can I put
this more solution oriented like before
I would focus on the problem [ __ ] about
it wish you wish it wasn't there and now
I'm like okay problem what's the
solution
you know what I mean like boom Oh this
is a Texas accent okay okay thanks
you got me crazy to some people but
and the LSD
a state to have helped me uh form a
bridge of some kind that's the best way
I can put it I can't really articulate
it
that well but it seems to have
it's hard to explain yeah I think it's
like what we were talking about on the
with the previous call it's this kind of
Spotlight I think it's it's it really
does kind of you know zero in on what's
going on with you and so you know like
like as you described it a kind of a
problem and so it's okay well I've got
this what am I going to do about it okay
very good so Jimmy they're uh very very
strongly calling into a drug show of
some kind which
um
it's fascinating I don't know what else
to say I want to say thank you to some
great people that are at 77 Ryder Prime
and book loving mom who just re-upped
their twitch subscriptions putting us at
65 we are back on Twitch we were at
about a thousand twitch Subs when we
were ban hammered and uh we've worked
our way back up to 850. really
appreciate everybody we're moments from
the resumption of the closing statements
in the trial over the death of Ahmad
Arbury uh once we return I'm going to be
briefly stepping away I've got another
couple calls and I have to do a little
work on tomorrow's program but we're
going to continue with the closing
statements
um unclear whether the jury will get the
trial today
um or whether they will get it in some
subsequent subsequent day
um but that it remains to be seen oh
wait a second what is this
I just think I got some interesting news
here
oh friend's having a baby I was supposed
to see him
all right
wow
all right so I'm not going to see him
got it very good okay
uh
uh all right so we got that let's get to
a couple of other
um
let's a couple of other voicemails
before we get back here
David please I beg of you stop consuming
cappuccinos
in the afternoon or in the evening
cappuccinos are traditionally and
classically
meant to be consumed in the morning that
is true practice when I'm in Italy
that's what I do in the U.S I will have
an afternoon cappuccino sometimes okay
your consumption of cappuccinos at any
other point of the day that's not the
morning isn't direct violation of
international law and of many different
HIPAA laws okay so please stop consuming
cappuccinos at any other time that's not
the morning
okay please
I beg of you wow very very aggressive
there huh
yeah David the problem with this country
isn't people like you coming over from
Mexico or whatever yeah and this is
Argentina
coming from a true Native American
because I was born
in Dallas Texas
um in 1973 I am the Native American
um
you people like you don't think that I'm
a Native American because my ancestors
were born somewhere and came here but I
was born here in America so that makes
me a Native American but getting back to
my point the problem with this country
is sodomox like yourself
who continue to believe that your aim is
is a sex organ
we're going to get away from that that
is not a view that I endorse and
um
that's that's really really bad
uh very hateful and disgusting
hey David hey this is Steven from
Wisconsin uh yeah I just heard you
listen to a voicemail a little earlier
about the guy who was a republican who
helped some of the same beliefs that was
Bernie and Elizabeth Warren and you're
confused about that you thought it
didn't make much sense I just wanted to
talk I don't really think that's
confusing at all because I'm actually a
burning girl Republican myself so I
figured I could call in maybe open your
eyes a little bit clear it up yeah but
yeah I mean I'm a registered Republican
I voted for Bernie I just I like his
ideas about wealth distribution
increasing the taxes on the wealthy
I actually think that I think that a lot
of what marks would think makes a lot of
sense too I read it I mean it's
Manifesto almost daily I keep it on my
nightstand actually overall I think that
is that believable like even if like
why would you read The Communist
Manifesto daily
like why is it necessary to read it
daily
chairman now darling those you know they
were just more or less all right so it's
obviously a joke but it's pretty funny
um all right let's see what else we've
got here
so about like Republicans
decriminalizing marijuana like I thought
about making an illegal again just
because
I don't know the transgender surgeries
and just not really feeling like people
are taking life seriously enough
um and then I went into thinking about
it more
um like it should be legalized for pain
and then I went into thinking about like
how that could impact people
um you know just based on like their oh
boy it's it's all getting pretty crazy
let me dip in a little bit further I
actually am glad to have this
opportunity because we've just been
unable
to catch up on so many of these
David it is Blake from Portland again I
am just wondering why in the world this
judge is just
itching to get out of this yeah a lot of
the unlistened to voicemails are about
the Rittenhouse trial and it's it's over
so
I don't want to just be focused only on
that
back then what up what up what up yeah
sorry about the noisy background I'm
this is the San Antonio troll my kid I
actually named him it's a newborn ninja
I named him David back now no I'm joking
I didn't name him David second but I
will have him
uh send you troll calls as soon as he's
old enough to do so
uh but I want to ask you
how you feel about
um
the
all these so many progressives and
Democrats like 67 for this office of
victims I don't even want to say victim
but the uh people were shot in this
Written House thing okay dude this guy
is so boring he's so so so boring it's
it's genuinely crazy
um
let me see if we've got anything else
here
oh uh this guy is calling in again David
some of your listeners or viewers may
have mischaracterized what the people
over at tyt have said or maybe I'm
getting that message from you I haven't
said anything about it so it is
there were there were people in the chat
talking about tyt and Rittenhouse I
didn't see it I didn't comment on it so
I don't need more people than now
commenting on something I didn't even
see it's it's not good I understand the
sarcasm of that person
tweeting you or whatever it's called
about uh advice from Joe Rogan asking
about colonoscopy and all but seriously
if there's enough people on the right
who view Fox and Newsmax and Joe Rogan
and uh Infowars and they will take
advice from Joe Rogan why not take
advice from Sean Hannity [ __ ] after all
Sean handy was a uh we went into radio
he was what I um
a plumber or a contractor
so if that qualifies him to give medical
advice
even more than me and I was an EMT [ __ ]
wow
wow wow wow
um okay
left a bunch of others
um
dystopia
all right we're done with those for now
the judge is back we're going to get
back to this
we're back on defense president
represented by Council
the
Greg McMichael
listen are you ready okay all right
let's get the panel
they are bringing the jury back in the
next defensive closing statement will
start I do want to say thanks to the
Mike Lennon and beloved but benevolent
goddess for signing up via twitch Prime
we are so glad to be back on Twitch I
also want to invite all of you to sign
up on my website joinpakman.com we have
a new coupon code that code is Obama
Obama and gives you a 68 discount
we've been advised by Council that at 69
the discounts draw the attention of
state and federal authorities so we're
keeping it to 68 for today
but I invite all of you to sign up we um
I'm going to be stepping away
momentarily
uh to deal with a couple phone calls and
different things the stream will
continue of course
and we don't know exactly what to expect
but the jury will be getting this case
relatively soon
other super chats the U.S should put a
Kyle on every street corner yeah there's
an idea
does Whitney know we've never heard a
full voicemail
all right jury's back
and then uh I will be back very very
soon
when you say it
all right welcome back hopefully
everybody enjoyed their lunch I
understand we are ready to proceed with
closing arguments the Civic on behalf of
Gregory McMichael thank you
on the next break we have something we
need to put on the record that
transpired over lunch my apologies
foreign
my father
worked for almost 50 years as a life
insurance salesman not because he liked
it
because he didn't
he did it because he had three kids
that he wanted to see grow up in a
neighborhood that was safe and secure
a safe home
surrounded by a community of neighbors
who cared for each other
Band-Aids for skinned knees
July 4th parties block parties that went
on for hours
crocheted baby blankets when a new child
was born
casseroles
when we'd lost a loved one
he worked hard day and night to provide
those things
for the people that he loved
Larry English
was a contractor in Douglas Georgia
who worked hard every day to provide for
his wife and two children
and to save for his dream
to live on the water
in a neighborhood just like that
safe
secure
filled with people who would care for
each other
and when he became ill
he and his wife Amy had to fast forward
their dreams
they fast forwarded that retirement
dream
bought that land
and began working on their dream home
the project of building that home
in Satilla Shores
it's the sort of life we all have the
right to seek the Safety and Security
and comfort
of people that we care about
and who care about us
we work hard for our stuff it's ours and
no one has the right to take it
and we should never ever have to fear
Intruders
the police can be counted on to help to
respond
but they can't be everywhere and they
can't be everything a good neighborhood
is always policing itself
Mr Moore you really need to put a fence
around that swimming pool I'm worried a
child will fall in
Mrs panock
Bobby is flying down Crossbrook drive
again in that new car
you have to talk with him and get him to
slow down so no one is hurt
the police can't be everywhere
and in a safe secure neighborhood
police are helped by those Neighbors
officer rash testified neighbors help
Neighbors
and neighbors help the police
there are really only two questions for
you to answer to reach your verdict in
the charges that the state has brought
against Greg McMichael
did Greg McMichael have reasonable and
probable grounds of Suspicion to believe
that Ahmad Aubry had committed a
burglary at 220 Satilla Drive
and did he have reasonable and probable
grounds to believe that Ahmad Aubry was
escaping or attempting to escape yet
again
on February 23rd
it is a nine count indictment
nine counts
so why only two questions
well I want to suggest to you
what the state suggested but in reverse
I'd like to suggest a methodical
efficient way to think about all this
law and all these charges
I suggest that you begin at the
beginning
count one
malice murder
and then take all the rest of those
counts two through nine as one big chunk
as you consider these important
questions
even count one at malice murder count is
defended by the answers to those
questions but with malice murder I
suggest to you you don't even have to
get to those questions
Greg McMichael pulled no trigger
how could the state seek a conviction
for malice murder
as Greg stood in the bed of the pickup
truck on the phone with 9-1-1 as the
Fatal shots were fired
as a party to the crime Miss dunnakoski
told you about the law that the judge
will give you if someone intentionally
helps or AIDS or procures or hires or
assists in the commission of a crime
they can be as guilty as the principal
as the person who fired the shots
but what is so
very different about count one
is that it's malice murder
it requires the desire and the intent to
kill the deliberate intention
take the life
of another human being
where all of the circumstances of The
Killing
show that an individual acted with an
abandoned
and malignant heart
the state will have to be asking you to
find
that Greg McMichael advised or
encouraged Travis McMichael his son
to take the life of Ahmad Aubry because
that's what he wanted to do
for no reason other than to see that
young man die
and to see him die at the hands of his
own son
and to do it right there in front of his
eyes
because the God keeps breaking down and
breaking into that house down the street
that's the level of Criminal Intent the
level of depravity heartlessness
sickness
that you would need to find
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
to find Greg McMichael guilty of malice
murder
that's why I suggest that you begin with
count one
and quickly dispatch of it with a not
guilty verdict
and then move down to the remaining
counts counts two through nine
because it comes down to this
if Greg McMichael was authorized by law
to attempt to execute a citizen's arrest
to try to detain Ahmad arbory for the
police to come and do their job
to try to keep peace and safety within
that neighborhood
then they were within the law to hold
him there for the police
how else does one hold an individual who
does not want to be arrested for the
police
you have to contain him not false
imprisoned him
contain him
you have to possibly hold him at
gunpoint
without firing a shot
not an aggravated assault
but the use of a reasonable and measured
amount of force to make him stay where
he did not want to stay
so if they were acting within the law
in trying to execute a citizen's arrest
to detain a mod Army for the police then
Travis had every single right to defend
himself
when Ahmad Aubry
inexplicably to that sharp left turn at
the right front of the truck
seeking to disarm Travis McMichael
so
who's got to prove what we begin as we
always begin in a courtroom
with innocence
and we stay there unless and until the
state proves to you that this was not a
citizen's arrest and that Travis was not
justified in defending himself against
Ahmad arbory's attack and they have to
convince you of that
remove your belief
in that
citizens arrest or justification to such
a degree that you've got left nothing in
your minds to doubt it
and that sounds like an enormous burden
why
because they have to make you sure of it
you have to have no hesitation no
ambivalence absolute certainty because
the stakes are as high as they come
it's the highest level of proof we ever
ask for in a courtroom
the court will tell you
when they say murder
and the facts raise justification
and the judge will tell you
justification is self-defense
justification is citizens arrest
that when that the facts are raised
to support those defenses
that the state has to disprove them
that you were Justified
but why why is the standard so
incredibly High
and the answer is something you
witnessed In This Very courtroom
even in science
errors can happen
and without diligent investigation and
inquiry people can be convicted on the
slightest errors
stripped of their freedom for another's
inattention or mistakes imagine if Dr
Donahue with all that experience
who made the decision the conclusion
that the muzzle to target range the end
of Travis's shotgun to the chest of
Ahmad Arbury
was four feet away based on a
photography compared in a book
without having watched the video and
more egregiously without even having
looked at the clothes that covered Ahmad
aubry's body imagine if that initial
conclusion
had been all you knew in this case
wouldn't that have misled you
wouldn't that have led you to wonder how
what you saw in that video
could match the opinion of a scientist
imagine if Brian leopard
hadn't tested Ahmad arbory's shirt
and scientifically concluded based on
that stippling that these were contact
or near contact wounds imagine further
if I hadn't emailed Dr Donahue
to take another look at his conclusions
based upon the clothing and Brian
leopard's expert report
and further imagine
if Dr Donahue was not an honorable
scientist
if he wasn't willing to admit he'd made
a mistake
and take another look
at the science
so that instead of three to four feet
we now know if contact
or three inches three inches
as opposed to four feet
that
that is a demonstration to you
why this system has to work this way why
the state has such a high burden
with evidence that leaves absolutely no
reason to doubt
before any one of you can consider
declaring that a man seeking to protect
himself and his community
is a murderer
you determine the facts
and the judge will tell you the law
so of course you need to be given the
facts accurately
and completely
the painful
Beauty
of this case
is that almost all of it
is recorded
security videos from outside people's
homes on Satilla in Satilla Shores
difficult to listen to 9-1-1 tapes
and then of course
the really hard thing to look at
the cell phone video that captured the
last moments
based on those
Undisputed recorded facts
still in the face
of all that you heard and saw
the state's case demonstrated an opening
State at what Mr hope told you an
opening statement he told you Greg
McMichael was absolutely certain
and he was absolutely right
you were so attentive
and I thank you for that
we all do
you took a lot of notes and there was a
lot of things to take notes about
so you know
that the very first words
out of Greg took Michael's mouth
is that there was no doubt in his mind
as to who this guy was he told officer
bran to marry that and it was captured
on the body Cam that you saw
and later in interviewed at the GB
excuse me interviewed at the Glenn
County Police Department by Parker Marcy
that investigator told you
here's his statement here's what he told
me I watched him and when he came by me
I got a good really good look at him so
I mean it's the same guy and it was
Ahmad Aubry on the video
he was an intruder
Larry English had reported because he
believed that an intruder had taken
thousands of dollars of boat equipment
off the offshore boat that had been
parked in his RV parking garage
it was Ahmad Aubry returning night after
night
without Authority
to a place where valuables were stored
with no legitimate reason for being
there
and it was Ahmad Arbury as Greg
McMichael told immediately after being
questioned who had hauled ass
from that house on February 23rd
after he'd looked through the window
at Mad Al benze on the phone
that he ran from that home
add all that knowledge that certainty
to what he learned when Travis jumped
into the truck and shared with him what
he saw on the driver's side of that
truck
that's not an Evidence and I object to
that this is never an Evidence and state
of gesture arguing facts on another John
I believe that is an Evidence and I
believe that Travis McMichael testified
and these statements that I'm talking
about did come into evidence I believe
it yet the jury to remember the evidence
all right ladies and gentlemen it is up
to the jury to recall the evidence that
has been presented in this trial lawyers
say is not evidence so it is up to you
to recall what the evidence is in the
case and you go ahead and address
this matter on that basis I don't have a
complete listing of all statements made
but it's up to you ladies and gentlemen
to recall that just because the lawyer
says something again does not mean it is
evidence and this is argument go ahead
you will be the decider of the fact you
took the notes and I trust what you will
remember from this trial
that Travis jumped into the driver's
seat of that truck after having seen
Matt albenze standing in front of 220
Satilla drive and pointing down that
street
signaling down that street
that the man
that Travis McMichael had seen only 11
days earlier with his own eyes
and then slowly pulled up alongside so
that he could confirm for himself
that's right
this is the guy
and the judge will tell you you will
gather the facts from the totality of
the circumstances did they have a
reasonable and probable cause to believe
that this was the guy
and you can know and the judge will tell
you that you gather that from every
sense that you have
you're hearing
your sight
your sense of what's going on around you
certainty though
is a way higher standard than what you
even need to find in this case
certainty was way more
knowledge
then they needed to detain Ahmad Ahri to
execute a citizen's arrest and that was
Greg McMichael's intent he said it from
the very beginning he was asked by the
investigator Parker Marcy testified to
you what was your intent had he had had
he stopped
and he said as clear as a bell
hold him for the police
so that he could be arrested
the judge will charge you that a private
citizen can effectuate an arrest
detaining someone for the police to
arrive if a crime happens within his
knowledge but here's the other one
or his immediate presence
thanks Jason I appreciate it
so here's what you have to know
that you haven't yet heard from the
state
there are no magic words
that are required the court will tell
you there's nothing special you have to
say
to be effectuating a citizen's arrest
there's nothing special you can't say
while effectuating a citizen's arrest
if it happens within your knowledge or
immediate presence
then you can effectuate a citizen's
arrest and Criminal Trespass the court
will tell you going on someone's
property without the authority and for
an unlawful purpose
is citizen is is a crime the misdemeanor
offense of citizens arrests and again
what you haven't heard from the state
and got some misdirection about
there's no requirement
judge Walmsley will tell you for a
posting of a no trespassing sign there's
no requirement that any officer execute
this trespass warning
it's your place
and people should stay off it we don't
need to be telling people ahead of time
and giving them warnings if you don't
want to
and he'll also charge you that as
private citizen can effectuate an arrest
detaining someone for the goal of
holding them for the police
if he has reasonable grounds of
Suspicion to believe that a suspect is
fleeing or attempting to flee from a
felony burglary is a felony
entering a dwelling place without
Authority with the intent to commit
effect in there not an actual theft
but the reason the mindset for going
into a place that's not yours
so how do you know that if there wasn't
actually an effect
judge Walmsley will tell you
the law will allow you to infer an
intent to steal
if there's an unlawful entry meaning
Crossing into a place that's not yours
a place where valuables are stored and
you heard testimony that plenty of
valuables were stored at 220 Satilla
Drive
with no other apparent motive for being
there
that means every single time
Ahmad arbory goes into that house
he is committing a burglary
but you hardly needed a jury instruction
to tell you that
coming into someone else's house
at night
where it's pitch dark
repeatedly even after you've been run
off
into a place where an offshore boat is
holding expensive equipment
the Intruder comes in
and sometime after that Intruder has
left your stuff is gone
reasonable grounds of Suspicion
is nothing more
10 probable cause
and probable cause
as Mr Sheffield
and the court will tell you
are facts necessary to establish a
probability
you're likely than not
it's less than certainty
but it's more than mere suspicion
so think of it this way if officer rash
had been on one of his Patrols in
Satilla Shores on February 23rd at about
108 pm
and as he turned onto Satilla Drive
he saw Matt albenze
who he'd already met
up standing in front of 220 Satilla
drive just signaling down that street
and down that street
I tail in it
is a mod Aubry
the man that officer rash has seen on
those video cameras over and over again
so if he saw and heard
what these men did
he too
would have had probable cause to arrest
Ahmad Arby for the crime of burglary
there's no doubt he would have put on
his sirens
and try to stop a mod arbory and there's
no doubt after the events of February
11th that officer rash would have had
his gun at the ready
and not taking any chances
and I suspect
in your minds
there would be no doubt
that a mod arbory would have known
exactly why he was being chased
because there can be little doubt as
well
that Ahmad Arbury knew exactly why the
big Michaels were trying to detain him
on February 23rd
foreign
the truth of life is that it's very
complicated
a beautiful teenager with a broad smile
in a crooked baseball cap
can go astray
he can deteriorate
and lose his way
and years later
he can end up creeping into a home that
is not his own
and running away
instead of facing the consequences
acting erratically when approached
and making terrible
unexpected
illogical choices
but a mother's love doesn't fade
from that beautiful boy
in the ball cap
to the young intruder
and sadly no verdict
can change the grief of that future not
realized
the hope that he could have turned
himself around
because all we can guess about the young
man
is that his teenage years were full of
promise
but his early 20s just led him in the
wrong direction
the facts presented in this trial
they are no resemblance
to the story that the state told you an
opening statement
a 25 year old
who met a brutal death
after being chased and killed by
residents of a neighborhood who wanted
nothing more than to murder him
for having the audacity to jog in their
neighborhood
not a single piece of evidence that's
been presented to you in this entire
trial
supports such a hateful and gruesome set
of circumstances
turning Ahmad arbory into a victim
after the choices that he made does not
reflect the reality of what brought
Ahmad Aubry to Satilla Shores
in his khaki shorts
with no socks
to cover his long dirty toenails
there were two sets of decision makers
on February 23rd
it is not just the McMichael's decisions
that led to this tragedy
and it is
a tragedy
I see it in your faces
and I have felt it in mine
a young life lost
grieving parents
Greg and Travis didn't have to do
anything on February 23rd Greg could
have looked up
from his boat cushions
saw marred Arbury run past and shrug his
shoulders
maybe call 9-1-1
maybe call officer rash
maybe text Diego Perez
and the fear
and the frustration of this neighborhood
would continue
but Greg McMichael's driveway decision
wasn't the only decision
that set this tragedy in motion
Ahmad Arbury was not an innocent victim
plundering through Larry english's house
on February 23rd
just as he wasn't an innocent victim
all the other nights
like October 25th
or November 18th
or December 15th or February 11th
is he the person responsible for
stealing Larry english's expensive boat
equipment I don't know we don't know no
one investigated that
but can anyone reasonably believe
that Ahmad Aubry was just doing a lookie
Lou
on those nights
in what has been described and shown to
you
as a home
drenched in absolute Darkness
the judge will instruct you
that you must use common sense and
reason
common sense and reason
there was no legitimate reason
for Ahmad arbory to be plundering
through Larry english's house those four
nights
and again on the afternoon of February
23rd
Ahmad didn't live there
he didn't work there he didn't have
friends there he didn't have a
girlfriend there he wasn't hanging out
with a friend in that neighborhood who
was a friend of a friend he didn't jog
through that neighborhood
he was a recurring
nighttime intruder
and that is frightening
and unsettling
a lookie Lou
in an open unsecured construction site
why did we have to withstand that drum
beat why
let's clear a few things up
the judge will charge you that for
burglary purposes a dwelling is any
structure that is intended for
residential use it makes no difference
if it's occupied being built under
construction unoccupied or vacant
and that only makes sense
how could you ever build a home
if it wasn't really yours to protect
until it was done
for that matter how could you ever
expect your stuff to be safe when your
teenager forgets to close the garage
door
really with all the important law to
consider
why the misdirection why
and why the insensitivity
to the neighbors of Satilla Shores
it's only a lookie-loo
when it isn't your neighborhood
it's only an open uncon on open
unsecured construction site
when it's not the building of your dream
home
hastened
by this impending fatal illness of Larry
english's
it's only a property crime
when you're not subie Lawrence
across the street from that house living
alone trying to raise three rambunctious
boys
and you can't even let them outside to
play
it's only a property crime
if you're not Diego and Brooke Perez
trying to raise three little girls
safely next door to 220 Satilla Drive
no one but Ahmad Aubry
made the decision to repeatedly and
unlawfully enter into that house over
and over again
no one but Ahmad arbory made the
decision to run like the wind
when the police car responded to the
calls from the owner and the neighbors
no one but Ahmad arbory made the
decision to either reach for or
certainly give the very real impression
that he was reaching for a handgun on
February 11th
and then to yet again run away when the
police arrived
and no one but Ahmad Aubry
made the decision not to stop
when Travis's truck rolled up beside him
to wait
to tell the police what he was doing
there
or just plane run away Into the Woods
or in the culverts that you'll see all
over the state's evidence or the open
yards or the open garages or yell the
word help or just keep going right
straight down Satilla drive right into
officer Min shoes
patrol car
I realize
probably more than any of you
what an incredibly unpopular thing that
is to say
but in a courtroom
with Greg McMichael facing the charge of
murder
Somebody's gotta say it
and believe me I'm proud to be the one
to say
Not to cause harm and to cause pain
but because
the truth in this place is really all
that matters
be very clear be very clear
no one is saying that Ahmad Arbury
deserved to die for whatever it was he
was doing inside 220 Satilla drive
because that's not why he died
he died
because for whatever
inexplicable illogical reason
instead of
staying where he was
whatever overwhelming reason he had to
avoid being captured that day and
arrested by the police
he chose to fight
he chose to fight
to
without under any sense of reason
to run
at a man wielding a shotgun
leaving him with no other alternative
but to be placed in the position
killing
another human being
Greg McMichael
had probable cause through all that he
saw
all that he heard
all that he knew
to believe reasonably that Ahmad Arbury
had committed a crime
and that he was fleeing from it yet
again
if the state hasn't removed
every doubt every single reasonable
logical doubt in your mind
that Greg McMichael was attempting a
citizen's arrest attempting to Simply
detain Ahmad Arbury for the police on
February 23rd then you have reached your
verdict ladies and gentlemen on counts
two through nine
if they can't strip you
of any reason to doubt the evidence
that's been presented to you
on citizens arrest
but
if they
have left you
wanting to know more
if they have left you wanting to inquire
into the next steps
of these offenses there are still more
steps
one of those is causation
how any of the other acts in counts two
through nine
other than the actual shooting of Ahmad
arbory could have been the direct cause
of Ahmad arbory's death
or
that it would have played a substantial
and necessary part in causing the death
you would have to find
that the goal of trying to detain Ahmad
Aubry for the police
without using any excessive force no
fists no discharge of the weapon
before that left turn attack on Travis
then
the case is over yet again on counts two
through nine it would have to be not
guilty because there would have been no
causation between the counts that don't
involve the actual discharge of that
firearm
and that if you wanted to go one further
step
you would have to ask yourself
about Greg's role in all of this
while riding in the back of the pickup
truck
as a party to the crime
the state would have to prove to you
but Travis McMichael intent excuse me
that Gregory McMichael intentionally
helped in the commission of the shooting
or advise encouraged hired counseled or
procured Travis McMichael to shoot Ahmad
Arbury as he was on the phone with 9-1-1
shouting the word
no
without proof Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
of all of those pieces all of those
elements
the state simply has not met their case
when I sit down
I get no more chance to speak with you
and that's a tough thing for me
I have to know that the state gets the
last word
so given the state's opening and some of
their cross-examination of witnesses
despite how careful I know you all were
with your notepads and pens with your
attention with your focus
I have to raise a few more things to
make sure you notice them because the
states
are so incredibly High
Miss dunakovski told you in her initial
closing argument she was afraid that
we'd persuade you
of the things that we're sharing with
you about the state's case
I'm afraid that she's going to cherry
pick
cherry picking is this it's
shizzing and taking only the most
beneficial items from all that's been
provided to you and trying to turn that
into a fact don't look over there at all
the rest of the stuff just look at these
beautiful cherries I've picked
context determines meaning
stop
or I'll blow your M effing head off
you heard that from opening statement
and you heard it all the way through the
trial cross-examination
versus the actual reality
that I think I saw you all wrote it
right down of what Greg McMichael told
Parker Marcy and what the investigators
testified about what it really meant and
when it really was supposed to have
happened
Greg McMichael said that horrible
sentence
or something stop he said to the
investigator I said to him stop or I'll
blow your MFE head off or or something
you didn't hear
or something
but most importantly
what we now know
is that Greg McMichael fought
in the panic and adrenaline and fear and
of that horrible situation
he thought that's what he said
at the very end of this encounter Mr Ho
cross-examined every Witness
who was with Greg McMichael when he
shared that piece of information
the D.A wants to make you think
by cherry picking
that Greg McMichaels said that anywhere
anytime over and over all through
anywhere through the pathway
but what those Witnesses those
investigators and officers told you
is that Greg McMichael
was talking about the final encounter
officer brandeberry was asked when did
you understand he was telling you he
said that
and officer brandeberry said he's
talking about the final encounter on
Holmes Road
yes that's my understanding
Parker Marcy was asked
when would that have occurred would that
have occurred giving the context of the
full statement which because of the laws
in this courtroom you and around the
state of Georgia you cannot have all of
the statement read to you so there had
to be context
and that gets a little dicey and that's
why you have to be extra careful when
you're sharing that information with a
jury
so Mr hope cross-examined those officers
to say let's draw down on when that was
supposed to have happened
he said it was supposed to have happened
at the final confrontation the same
place where Greg's on the phone with
9-1-1 yes
that's what he thought he said so
whatever he said on 9-1-1 Mr Hogue asked
the investigator would that be the most
accurate
way of knowing what he really said and
that investigator just like all of you
would say
of course
whatever you heard
whatever the state presented in the
9-1-1 call whatever you can listen to
again
there's no resemblance
to what Greg McMichael after a stroke
in the panic and the fear and the
sadness of those moments when he was
interviewed thought that he said on the
9-1-1 call
you are the decider of the facts you're
the ones that are going to have to make
the decision about what's true and
what's not true about this case
Jason Sheffield said the word red
herring so I went ahead and looked it up
I've always heard that phrase and the
definition is something that's intended
to be misleading or distracting
so I'm going to tell you I've got one
more concern before I sit down
and that is that could be completely
wrong about this but I'm concerned about
it so I want to share it with you since
I can't come back up in case my
suspicions are correct
I'm afraid of why the state kept
introducing into evidence
still shots
of Greg McMichael with various people
scene
I noted them
in the beginning thinking it wasn't any
big deal I take down a lot of notes like
you all do and then I kept seeing a
pattern and again Miss Santa clauski I
could be completely wrong about this
but I'm concerned that Ms donekowski is
now digging so deep
to make this case
that she's going to suggest to you
that great McMichael was on that scene
manipulating testimony and evidence
it seems
kind of wild when you think
that the whole event is on video
and that the people that came in with
that video said it hadn't been altered
or changed in any way
and that officer minshu was there in
seconds on the scene and we see
everything that's happening on his body
cam
in fact it was Travis and Greg who waved
him down
but there's photos of Greg comforting
his son
there's a photo of Greg McMichael after
30 years in law enforcement having a
conversation with Captain Tom jump
there's evidence that the film Miss
officer minshu said Roddy's got this on
the film and track and Greg who's able
to say Travis it's captured on film
there's a screenshot of Diego talking to
Greg even though officer Adam Jackson
Who testified said I spoke to Diego
Perez he said I got some camera footage
you wanted
and we got the security camera footage
from Diego Perez through Adam Jackson
unadulterated and presented to you
so I just have to say
thank goodness
that is awful as those recordings are to
hear and see
they reflect the truth of what happened
who did what
and why
and there is no way
to suggest that there was any
manipulation of evidence
or testimony of the scene
so now
it's time very soon probably not soon
enough for you but very soon
for you to deliberate and reach a
verdict a verdict
rendered by members of your community
about an event that happened in your
community Glenn County
filled with communities
that are filled with neighbors
why did it take us 11 days
to select you
well the media descended on this case
and unless I think several Because
unless you lived under a rock you knew
something about the case
the facts that were accurate
some facts that were ridiculous
and some facts that were outright
slanted for shock value
and we as humans do we begin to form
opinions
when we begin to hear things that we
believe could be facts
and then there's the social media people
posting arguments comments and opinions
and then with the algorithm of Facebook
you're going to get more and more of the
same opinions and comments and opinions
that are like the opinions that you seem
to be interested in and next thing you
know you think that these people's
opinions are facts
and the other issue is this is a small
County
many of the jurors that were summoned
knew the defendants
many of the jurors that were summoned
knew the arteries many of the jurors
that were some are new people who were
close to people who knew either one of
them
and consistent with human nature those
folks had formed opinions
so why are you the 15 that remained
because you were determined to be the
people most likely to do
what I submit to you is The Impossible
to set aside
opinions and beliefs you'd formed before
you came into court
to set aside facts that you thought were
accurate before you came to court and to
promise with your oath hand to God
to base your verdict only on what you
hear in this courtroom
it's kind of a ridiculous standard but
it's all we've got
for these men to have their day in court
and we had to assess
your honesty
we had to assess your candor your
truthfulness that you would do what you
said you would do
this incredible awesome responsibility
that you've been selected to undertake
jury deliberations are not like a
meeting
they're not like a business meeting
where you're going to each put in your
opinions and thoughts and reach an
agreement a little give and take
it's not like going to buy a car and
you're Dickering over the price it's not
even like the legislature when they're
trying to come up with a budget hey this
is the stuff I really want in my packet
and this is the stuff I really want in
my packet I'll give up a little bit of
this if you give up a little bit of that
that is not at all how jury
deliberations work
because you see compromise has
absolutely no place
in the deliberative process
the judge will instruct you keep an open
mind talk with each other consider each
other's points of view but the bottom
line ladies and gentlemen
is that each of you
will form this verdict
on your own
you are The Gatekeepers of this jury
process
You're The Gatekeepers of the oath that
you each took
if some of you feel strongly one way
and others of you feel strongly the
other way
keep talking keep working this is
important
but you are not to give up
any opinions you have any thoughts and
beliefs you have
to get along or just to be unanimous
you are not to consider
what the possible punishments just might
be
you can't have the kind of conversation
that says well you know that now is
murder that is kind of ridiculous given
the facts of this case so let's just
agree on that felony murder that can't
be that bad it's got to be a less than
the malice murder
or you know some of you really want
felony murder and some of you really
want not guilty
if we just sort of meet in the middle
with one of those AG assaults
absolutely not
absolutely not I encourage you
I beg you
to slam on the brakes if you hear any
conversations like that in the Jury Room
the only thing you're asking yourself
is whether the state removed every
logical reason for you to doubt that
Greg McMichael had the requisite
knowledge and intent to execute a
citizen's arrest and if he if that's the
case
then not guilty is the only verdict you
can reach
because every single count in this
indictment
is so serious
and every single count in this
indictment is life changing for Greg
McMichael
your deliberations should be guided by
the rule that the judge will give you
if in any way
your minds are wavering
unsettled
unsatisfied
then that is a doubt of the law and you
must acquit
you can't wake up
in a couple of weeks from now
and regret the decision you made
because you can't take it back
the Constitution
our beautiful Constitution
demands no less
than this certainty
the grandparents on golf carts
in Satilla Shores
the kids on bikes in your neighborhood
the couples walking their dogs after
dinner
in our small town neighborhoods deserve
no less
Greg McMichael
is not a murderer
he's not guilty
foreign
we're going to take a let's take a
15-minute recess and we'll continue with
closing arguments again do not discuss
this case amongst yourselves until
you've been instructed to do so by the
court thank you
foreign
co-counsel
and the opportunity to look outside what
was going on and there are some matters
that need to be placed on the record
one moment
sorry Mr no no no you're good you're
good I'm not using any of that stuff
a lot of protesters uh whether they were
the Black Panther group or some other
group were behind the barriers in front
of the courthouse there was a truck
carrying a coffin with the names of the
defendants on it
um at least one of these groups I
believe it was the Black Panther group
is referenced in the motion file this
morning that their specific objective
was to influence the proceedings in this
case
I don't know whether they intended to
scare the defendants but I have
co-counsel with a small child who was
scared to death
um large weapons
apparently automatic weapons were seen
outside the courthouse
and you know given everything else
that's already transpired in this case
we believe at this point that it's
appropriate for us to renew the motion
from mistrial this core has gone to
Great Lengths to give these defendants a
fair trial but
the security precautions that were in
place despite the sheriff's best efforts
and your honors best efforts
we've now got people claiming to be
violent driving around the courthouse
with coffins with our clients names on
them with semi or fully automatic
weapons I mean I'm not sure that this is
no longer a figurative
mob this is a literal mob and inevitably
the proceedings despite that
entertainment we would move from
Australia
our position again is if the jury has
been exposed to it yes we would be
Gravely concerned and we would need them
to let the court know that they've seen
it that's had any influence on them
short of that if it's
if it's folks exercising their first
amendment rights outside and our jury is
unaware of it then we're okay and I
would agree with Mr Hogue that's what I
was going to say
and then I would one more thing
to make sure in this most important
trial that
the jurors are not
being exposed to these matters I would
ask the court to affirmatively question
them all together to remind them to
bring to your attention or the or the
court deputy's attention if they have
encountered it or been contacted anyway
State asked did you deny the motion for
mistrial we leave it to the discretion
of the Court
s again denying the mistrial I've
indicated
previously been mentioned to council
that I agree with the concern that is
out there uh
with regard to the jurors having
exposure to anything that may be going
on outside not uh uh whatever may be
going outside I have it has not been
brought to my attention on a security
level
again individuals have a right to be
outside the courthouse
I agree with Mr Hogue that the court
needs to keep a very close eye on
whether or not whatever may be going on
outside the courthouse is any influence
upon the jury and the court has taken
steps to ensure the jury is insulated
from anything going on around the
courthouse so that they can focus on
their business before the court which
would be to consider the evidence
presented as well as the arguments of
council that I will continue to have
done it to do so
Court talked with the jury bailiff at
all and and also keeping lines of
communication up with the jury bailiff
so that she would say judge there's some
murmurs or there's some things being
spoken is she keeping an active year out
for the court
without getting into detail I will tell
you that the court uh is I'm trying to
stay prized of whatever may be going on
with the jury as far as what's going on
outside that that's up to whoever's
outside making sure that everything's
okay as far as this jury is concerned
and what we may be going on that may
affect the proceedings in this courtroom
uh yes I have tried to ensure that I'm
at least aware of anything
that may be important enough to affect
the proceedings and if something did
happen I would
probably be bringing it to everybody's
attention because I think it'd be
important for Council to know
one other thing I wanted to move again
we replaced juror number 12.
um and I will tell you I've tried to mix
my contact with you during my closing
she she had nodded off she was she was
done she was uh sleeping and so um at
one point I walked closer to her to try
to rustle her up and I even think I
thought there was someone that might
have even moved her chair kind of kicked
it and she then still nodded back off
again so I would ask again since this is
now about the third or fourth time that
we've had to deal with it that we have
her replaced with the first ultimate we
would join that
after harvesting right in front of me I
never saw this her chair eyes open
so let's talk about what she saw so
what's up and I was facing his head
while she was talking about I was very
closely watching the jurors and Jericho
was very funny I did not see her not off
I didn't see her close her eyes at all I
saw her actively paying attention to
this that is what I saw I will again
start focusing on juror number 12 where
I think it's sitting close to the
balance now and make sure and for the
record genre is there if anyone else's
Council table that's able to indicate of
whether you agree with what I saw I
thought that you and I had made some eye
contact I must have misunderstood that
you I thought you were looking straight
at her
yeah I apologize I didn't mean to
interrupt Miss tunakowski I did see it
there were two times where I thought
about turning over a box accidentally or
kicking the table hard but I didn't want
to interrupt her Miss hugs closing but
there were two times
hearing a couple different things so I'm
going to keep an eye on juror number 12
again and ensure I did not see a juror
sleeping during closing arguments
um
but that of course is something
particularly with what has happened
previously that I know again start
keeping a close eye on
um
nodding off during his hopes
presentation I mean she may need medical
attention you may have a coma here
before I'm done
okay with that where he says let's go
about 10 minutes
wow
this is
all right
we're back on
defend his present
represented by Council Mr Goff you ready
to proceed
with another trumpet
film
s
all right we have everybody in place
Let's uh let's go get the panel
foreign
it's all right
foreign
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
I'm saying we are ready to proceed with
closing arguments Mr Goff yeah
when
when did Roddy Brian
know the McMichaels brought guns
when did Roddy Brian Know Travis
McMichael would shoot Mr Arbury
and at that point what could Roddy Brian
have done to stop it
the Inconvenient Truth is that Roddy
Brian did not know and could not know
that these men were armed until moments
before Mr arbury's tragic death
he did not know and could not know that
Arbury would be shot and by that time
sadly there was nothing Roddy Brian
could do to prevent this tragedy
Roddy Brian didn't shoot anyone at the
time of the shooting he was some
distance back
he was armed only with his cell phone
isn't it time
isn't good time ladies and gentlemen
that we send Roddy Brian home
thank you
Roddy Brian fully cooperated with the
police
he's given several different statements
he's provided the now famous video that
you've seen so many times and probably
will again before we're done
Roddy provided his cell phone multiple
times he signed all kinds of consent
forms he gives them access to his truck
he gives them the night owl videos from
his house the videos that had been
overlooked in the canvassing of the
neighborhood because he was down at the
police station
he gives them his social media he gives
them his Facebook
ladies and gentlemen without Roddy Brian
there is no case
you will have to decide what Justice
looks like between the McMichaels
and Mr Arbury
between the Nick Michaels and the Arbury
family
but the reason that you can do so the
reason that we can have this trial
is because of Roddy Bryant
Roddy's decision to cooperate with law
enforcement to help them discover the
truth about the events of February 23
2020. is not the product of slick
lawyering Roddy Brian had no lawyer on
the side of the road in the minutes
after Ahmad Arbury was shot
it was not some lawyer it was Roddy
Bryan without any lawyer without any
help without any assistance making that
decision on his own
Roddy Brian made the choice
right all right welcome back everybody I
want to briefly interrupt the third of
three closing defense statements we
still believe that this will be wrapping
today and whether jury deliberations
start today or not we don't know but I
did want to let you guys know about
something that's going on that we now
have some
um new video of as uh I have been saying
for weeks at the end of the
um Kyle Rittenhouse trial he would be
made a hero or a martyr
and because of the acquittals it's going
straight to Hero he won't first have to
be a martyr in jail
tonight Tucker Carlson is promoting an
exclusive interview with Kyle
Rittenhouse and we now have the first
clips and I'm going to be playing that
for you right now
I do want to say thank you to Blueberry
babe Master MC Levy Lake and bacon wolf
Knight albix for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 71 and also
a big thank you to Catherine Williams
who signed up on my website
joinpakman.com is new member number 72
we do have the new coupon code Obama
Obama which you can use okay so this is
it's pretty gross let's look at some of
these clips okay this is what we have an
hour of tonight we're gonna have an hour
of this tonight
here we go I tell everybody there what
happened I said I had to do it I just I
was just attacked I was dizzy I was
vomiting I I couldn't breathe okay
next clip
um
about race
this case has nothing to do with race
um it never had anything to do with race
it had to do with the right to
self-defense right
um I'm not a racist person I support the
BLM movement I support peacefully
demonstrating
and I believe there needs to be change I
believe there's a lot of prosecutorial
misconduct not just in my case but in
other cases
and it's just amazing it the the funny
thing here is
an 18 year old believes that Pro
believes there's prosecutorial
misconduct
okay
see
how how much a prosecutor can take
advantage of somebody yeah
and then one more clip here from Kyle
Rittenhouse that we're going to be
focusing on this tomorrow of course
it wasn't Kyle Redden house on trial in
Wisconsin it was the right to
self-defense on trial
and if I was convicted
no one would be able no one would ever
be privileged to defend their life
against attackers now uh that's quite a
stretch as you can imagine but uh okay
so we're gonna have all of that tomorrow
let's get back now to the third of three
closing statements from the defense here
Ahmad Arbury
why the prosecution felt it necessary to
phrase the things the way they did in
their opening statement it's done Mr
nakoski will have to answer to you for
I was unable to play it earlier but we
are now going to try and play the
excerpt from the interview with Mr Lowry
specifically that most damaging part of
his statement where he supposedly wishes
that he had hit Ahmad Arbury
um you said that you had you had hand
prints on your truck from where the guy
was trying to get into it
yeah I feel pretty sure that's what he
was doing I mean I can't say for sure
that he was up there he won't hold the
door I ain't getting a chance to get to
the door but after I angled him off the
side of the road you know uh and I kind
of went on past him because I didn't hit
him um but
you know I probably got past him a
little bit and he'd come up on me and I
could see him in my mirror and he's
coming over the door and I seen his
hands on him right behind the door
okay
ladies and gentlemen
in the video as opposed to the officer's
testimony you can see Mr Brian's
demeanor you can see his gestures and
his mannerisms and you can see that when
he says that he wished he hit Mr Arbury
he said that just after he says that he
didn't hit him
and he's expressing regret
because Mr R Berry has died
and maybe
if he hadn't gotten down where he was he
wouldn't have been shot
that is much much different in context
than to suggest that Roddy Brian
wished that he had hit Mr Arbury
that's a reflection of regret that Mr
Arbury was hurt by the McMichaels that's
certainly not a suggestion that he for
any ill will
and how many other instances of that do
we have in this case how many other
times has the District Attorney's Office
Fired cheap shots
at Roddy Bryant how many times have the
gbi taken cheap shots at Mr Brian
and in the end you may wish to ask
yourself why
now in the defense case and we we're not
we didn't do it we promised we wouldn't
but it's clear
that Mr Brian did not wish to strike Mr
Arbury that he never had any intention
of hurting Mr Arbury he never said
anything to the contrary
the evidence will show that he had no
knowledge no reason to believe that
anyone else out there meant to hurt or
shoot Mr Arbury
if they had a secret intention or desire
to do that it could not be known to him
now there is another excerpt that I want
to play from the minshu video only one
okay because again I think it shows you
Mr Brian's demeanor it has been
suggested by the state that much of what
Mr Brian says later is somehow and after
the fact rationalization
of what happened that day but when you
listen to this I think you'll see that
Mr Brian's the truth of what Mr Brian is
trying to convey hasn't really changed
hmm
I even almost
think I need to get away from this I
mean we don't want to have another issue
uh
uh with twitch spans right I mean
I'm just not even sure it's all very
very
unclear right now we're just gonna step
away from it and we'll have just the
audio we got to play it very very safe
uh
uh
yeah
so we'll just keep it here for a moment
I do want to say thanks to Kimmy
blacksmith for signing up at
joinpakman.com there's a reason we all
don't play more of these coupon code
Obama Obama
[Music]
what what
you know what did it look like he was
trying to do he was trying to get he was
trying to get on this side of the car
right it wasn't a little like he was
trying to do what yeah I mean I'd cut
him off pretty good now okay I mean he
put he actually pulled your handle
arms right there okay he's trying to get
the handle okay yeah yeah all right
all right did uh
you got it on video
at what point did you start videoing
well I thought he was going to get away
okay so that was so you was getting
trying to get okay capture who you look
like yeah I mean to be honest with you I
probably got two videos three videos I
mean I probably started over here I
don't know what I got because half the
time I was trying to drive
right
it was suggested
that Roddy Brian
made up the idea that he was trying to
preserve
Mr arberry's identity that he was trying
to preserve it because he thought he was
going to get away it's been suggested
that that's not what was going on
but yet here on the side of the road
with officer minshu
Roddy Brian says within minutes of the
shooting
that that's exactly what he was trying
to do
we have one video
in this case well we have two a shorter
version of the one you've seen But when
Mr Brian is talking with officer minshu
he hasn't had a chance to look at his
phone he hasn't had a chance to see what
he has he thinks he has two or three
videos he thinks he's caught much more
than he had
now either you believe that Roddy Brian
is the smartest person in this room
that he's playing games and manipulating
the police
from the moment this has happened
or you know that Roddy Bryant had good
faith from the start that he tried as
best he could to help the police
maybe it would have been better if he
had been able to record more if he knew
better how to operate his phone but the
idea that somehow Mr Bryan is quote
unquote minimizing his involvement in
this case
had he recovered as much video as he
thought he had
he might have had the whole thing on
video
and he's giving it to the police he's
inviting officer Mitchell to sit with
him in the car to look at it with him
for the first time
not with some slick Cobb County lawyer
by himself
that tells you
that Roddy Brian is not guilty because
unless you think he's smarter than
everybody else in this room that he's
smarter than all these police officers
that he's smarter than the cream of the
crop the creme de La Creme of the gbi
then you know he's trying to tell you
the truth he just can't always find the
words
and to hear again
all this stuff about Mr Brian about all
these things that happen we'll come back
to that later but
when you look at the Lowry interview
when you look at Mr Minch the the the
minshu discussion on the side of the
road
you know
you know what the truth is here
now
if I'm out of order I'm sorry
but again as I said before the events of
this day for Mr Brian's perspective are
chaos
Mr Brian doesn't know what happened up
the street at the English residence he
doesn't know Mr albenzi is out there he
doesn't know Mr albenzi's called 9-1-1
he assumes somebody's call 9-1-1 and he
was correct but he doesn't know
he doesn't know that Mr albenzi is armed
and just up the street
Mr Brian is not in communication with
anyone prior to the shooting not Mr
albenzi not Diego Perez not Gregory or
Travis McMichael at times as you've
heard Mr Brian feels like he's alone out
there with Mr Arbury
and it scares him
Ronnie Bryan doesn't see any guns until
moments before the shooting we'll come
back to that
I think if I recall correctly the
testimony was although you can see and
you will see in a moment Greg McMichael
standing in the back of the pickup truck
in the moments before the shooting
Mr Brian
on that day
doesn't even recall Gregory McMichael
being in the back of the truck
he doesn't realize Gregory McMichael's
in the back of the truck
until later until afterwards
Roddy Brian thinks that it takes the
police several minutes to arrive on the
scene when we know it was a mere it was
mere seconds
Roddy gets so many basic facts wrong so
many key facts
is it any surprise that months later he
would struggle to recall details of what
happened that day when he couldn't
recall big obvious details right at the
time it happened
let me shift gears for a moment
closing statement is sometimes referred
to as closing argument let me assure you
I don't want to argue about you with the
evidence first of all of you there's
only one million you can you get the
last word
second
you know lawyers we tend to remember
things frankly sometimes the way we
wanted them to be or the way we expected
them to be whereas you hear it as it
actually comes out so if my recollection
differs from yours I would trust your
Collective memory
and I'm not supposed to say this okay
we're all taught never to say this
but what we say as lawyers is not
evidence
the evidence is what you heard
and if something I say doesn't ring true
to you is what the evidence is
you don't have to wait for someone else
to object
I don't want you to consider something
if you don't remember it as the evidence
now before proceeding any further and
before I forget I do want to express my
gratitude to Mr Brian to the court to my
distinguished opposing counsel
as I walk through the front doors of our
Courthouse every day I am reminded oh my
God what an honor and absolute privilege
it has been to come for you
what I'd like to do now
is go back in time I'd like to list all
the black pastors that have been in the
room to the morning of February 23rd
2020. it seems at least to me both so
very far away and yet like it was
yesterday
it was a time to which many of us might
wish to return if only we could turn
back time
Ahmad Arbury is still very much alive
perhaps still asleep
some of us like Rook Perez and her
husband Diego have gone off to church
others read the Sunday paper
the politically minded may recall Bernie
Sanders is the front runner for the
Democrat nomination oh my God the sports
minded may recall that the Daytona the
Democrat had been held a week of
nomination down the road Donald Trump
was to Grand Marshal
in our local newspaper the Brunswick
News covers school events school events
celebrating Black History Month
you may recall cover 19. is still a
mystery covid-19 problem an Italian
problem
some guy we've never heard of Dr Anthony
fauci warns us that we should conserve
the already dwindling supply of masks
for First Responders and for health care
workers who most need them this is weird
but Roddy Ryan isn't reading the Sunday
paper
Roddy Brian is not in church
and he probably isn't paying much
attention to the corona Roddy Brian
is working
on the front porch of this home after
running for several years Roddy and his
fiancee have just purchased their home
on Burford
as a small engine repair guy working at
the local hardware store this is a big
deal for Roddy and he isn't going to
waste any time before facing it up
when you think back
it was a different world but it's the
world in which these events take place
and it's in that context that we have to
look at the evidence in this case
now
I think we have the First Night Out
video I call it the first night owl
video the porch video I think we played
it for you once we're just going to be
careful with the videos and the exhibits
here we know that you can see right all
pretty insane standing on his front
porch
trying to repair column
he is listening to music the music is
playing from the in the garage the door
is open
we've seen that from the previous
picture
you'll see the moment this truck is out
front let her know there was Kobe that
means not guilty behind him
okay this one's okay tools as well
yeah
we'll stop that
now we have a still photo which we're
about to turn back on
it's still fun sorry
Beggars can't be choosers so I'm gonna
wait on this part
now you see those rocking chairs there
of the Brian residence not guilty you
have to add in Mr Ryan I'm forged you
have to add in pickup truck in the
driveway with Lumber in the back
you have to imagine if you will the
music playing and it's probably playing
loud because his hearing is not so good
is there anything threatening or
menacing about this picture
or anything
threatening or menacing about this image
it's pretty weaponized law or is there
something we'd expect to see in a Norman
Rockwell painting
we talked about driveway decisions
Mr Arbury has driveway decisions that
he's making this morning
I'm not going back into all that stuff
with the englishes and Diego Perez and
Matt albansi and Robert rash that's
already been covered and although
Mr Brian May well have read about it on
the exit 29 page he doesn't recall it at
least on this day
but Mr Arbury is now running down the
street
running from the English residents
he's passing house after house after
house
on a nice Sunday afternoon innocent
houses
is there any evidence that Mr R Berry
sought hell sought assistance
from anyone in that neighborhood saw the
hell
maybe you heard it I did
but as he comes up to Mr Brian's
residence
he starts coming by his house
why isn't Mr Arbury
asking for help why isn't he calling out
hey somebody call 9-1-1 there's crazy
people after me
maybe that's because Mr Arbury doesn't
want help
now Mr Brian spots
Mr Arbury out of the corner of his eye
Roddy Brian knows the joggers in the
neighborhood it's interesting how it
being chaotic and stressful is used as
an excuse for the defendants
but it being chaotic the charitable
interpretation of it being chaotic and
stressful for Arbury is never used
intuitively and that's the word for it
intuitively
knows the difference between someone
running to something and someone running
from something
but that mystery is resolved pretty
quickly when the white pickup truck that
he does recognize from the neighborhood
comes by
now Roddy Brian doesn't know Travis
McMichael
he would recognize Greg but Greg
McMichael is sitting on a car seat
probably with his head stuck up
somewhere in the bed liner
Roddy Brian doesn't realize Greg
McMichaels in this truck too
after the tragic shooting
to anything about Robbie Bryant and
knowing Greg the Bible or anything I'm
pretty sure that he specifically said in
one of the interviews that we went
through
that he didn't realize breaking Michael
was in the truck but the jury knows what
the evidence is and they'll their
recollection controls
let's stick to the evidence I was
presented to the pan
thank you
oh man
I'm pretty sure the time that Mr Brian
looks out I'm pretty sure my client is
not guilty sir he sees that Mr Arbury in
the truck he sees them side by side
he cannot because of the music he really
can't hear the words I believe the
testimony is he's basically reading the
lips of what turns out to be Travis
McMichael
he can't see Mr arberry's lips he can't
see what if anything he's saying Mr
Brian has told us repeatedly that he's
never heard Mr Arbury say anything
from Day from the beginning to the end
so at this point
it's clear that Mr Arbury does not want
help from Mr Brian it's clear that he
he goes ahead and runs off
and at that point
Mr Brian has to make a decision now
there's been some testimony I think Mr
Brian said that he called out to them
you got him which would be consistent
with what he's seeing on the on the road
but
nobody else hears that that we know of
we know another witness said that they
didn't hear because they testified
and we're going to play a second Night
Out video that we didn't play previously
where you see Mr Brian coming off his
porch
now
I'm going to suggest to you and you will
have to decide what the truth is here
now Luther Bryan says he called out to
them
did he
do you see that on either of these
videos do you see it on the third one to
come
again
is Mr Brian relating what actually
happened or what he thinks has happened
it's Mr Brian's Mind Playing Tricks on
him
in any event
Mr Arbury goes down the street
Brian
at this point we're going to go to the
next night owl video
is he calling them night owl videos
sorry you went too quickly oops there he
is okay watch carefully
Mr Brian has said on some occasions he
walked to the kitchen on another
occasion he said he ran to the kitchen
he said he walked back out to the truck
another time he said he ran back out to
the truck what we know from this video
it takes 13 seconds to get from the edge
of the driveway into the kitchen to
reach the keys and go back out to the
truck
Mr Brian is in fact walking calmly to
the kitchen and walking calmly to the
truck and his recollection of doing
otherwise is faulty now we also know
as Mr Brian pulls out and by the way we
also know that he left his rifle in the
house
left a hammer on the porch
and went out with his cell phone
now here we see when Mr Brian initially
pulls out
Mr Brian
is pointed to the right
now he backs up
now it's at the very end he backs up and
he straightens out a bit
whether Mr Brian said he was going to
the left or the center or slightly to
the left
the actual evidence in the case
is consistent with him pulling straight
out
and again
we know from all the other things that
we've seen that Mr Brian's recollection
events that day simply the coffee oh man
now
Mr Arbury not Mr Arbury
Mr Brian
makes what is for him a very faithful
decision
he actually pulls out in the road
now at one point he says he overshot the
road another point in the same interview
with Detective Lowry he says that he
crept out onto the road
the state suggests that Mr Brian either
hit Mr Arbury or tried to hit him and
pushed him with his 5 000 pound motor
vehicle
we'll come back to that in a second but
I just don't think there's I think the
evidence is inconsistent with that
now I do want to talk about the
indictment for a minute
let's take a minute to review the
indictment
it is what we sometimes call a kitchen
sink indictment
everyone all three defendants are
charged literally with everything in the
indictment
every crime set forth therein you may
find this confusing and difficult to
sort through at times since the factual
bases and underlying legal bases for the
five
murder counts are so closely intertwined
with one another however this is
perfectly acceptable there's nothing
improper about it murder is murder
each of the remaining four counts of the
indictment aggravated assault with a
shotgun aggravated assault with a motor
vehicle or Motor Vehicles false
imprisonment and attempted false
imprisonment actually serve as predicate
felonies for the felony murder counts in
other words this indictment does not
allege any offense against any defendant
other than murder and the predicate
offense is former
there are a couple legal principles I
feel obligated to go over in every case
one of those is reasonable doubt I mean
you've already heard several very
capable lawyers go through that so I'm
not going to spend a whole lot of time
there
without belaboring the point however
I would refer you to what I consider the
core principles at the heart of the
Court's charge on Reasonable Doubt
A Reasonable Doubt means just what it
says it is the doubt of a fair-minded
impartial juror honestly seeking the
truth
if you are
a fair-minded impartial juror honestly
seeking the truth and you've certainly
given us every reason to believe that
you are
if at the end of the evidence you have a
doubt
that is a doubt upon which
you may acquit the defendant
A Reasonable Doubt is a doubt based on
common sense it is a doubt for which a
reason can be given
if you can give a reason to doubt
whether Mr Brian is guilty
then your mission is complete
and at that point you should equip Mr
Brian
now
also
often use this
provision lifted from Robert Bolt a man
for all seasons when I talk about
Reasonable Doubt
because I find it helpful
and let's be clear it is not a statement
of the law it is the principle behind it
you some of you may be familiar with the
play in the movie some of you may not
William Roper asks Sir Thomas Moore so
now you give the devil the benefit of
law this is weird Sir Thomas More says
yes what would you do cut a great Road
through the law to get after the devil
William Roper says yes I'd cut down
every law in England to do that
Sir Thomas More replies oh and when the
last law was down and the devil turned
round on you where would you hide Roper
the law is all being flat
this country is planted thick with laws
from coast to coast man's laws not gods
and if you cut them down and you're just
a man to do it do you really think you
could stand upright in the winds that
would blow them yes I give the devil
benefit of law
Sir Thomas More says
for my own safety's sake
and when you apply the Reasonable Doubt
standard
remember that standard that legal
principle isn't there
for Roddy Ryan it's not there for these
other defendants it's there for all of
us
and it's a principle that we cannot
forsake
the Court's going to charge you I
believe without trying to put words in
his mouth on parties to a crime
the provision that's relevant to Mr
Brian in this case is the second one to
be a party to the crime Mr Brian must
intentionally help in the commission of
an offense of a crime what could the guy
possibly be writing given that this is
the last word for the defenses these are
the closing statements like what is it
what is the guy writing be a party to
the crime intentionally
and we'll come back to that principle
again
now
count one is murder and
I Don't Want To Tread over the same
ground that other Council have tread but
the the issues are somewhat different
from Mr Brian
I hesitate even to respond to count one
because by doing so I don't want any of
you to think for a moment that there's
anything here even worthy of a reply
but I am required to do so
Roddy Brian didn't shoot Mr Arbury he
was armed only with a cell phone and he
was a good distance away when the shots
rang out Roddy did not cause and could
not cause Mr arberry's death within the
meaning of this statute
Roddy was not the shooter so he could
not shoot Mr Arbury unlawfully Roddy did
not shoot him at all Roddy Brian acted
in good faith on the day in question
there is no evidence whatsoever of
malice
and most importantly and I get I think
this Echoes arguments made by others
nor can Roddy be a party to the crime of
malice murder because there is no
evidence that Roddy Brian intentionally
helped Travis McMichael murder Mr Arbury
where is that evidence and that takes us
back to the three questions I asked a
moment ago when I first stood up
Roddy Bryant certainly was not aware of
any intention on the part of Travis
McMichael to shoot Mr Arbury and I'm not
saying he had that intention
you will have to decide
what Travis McMichael did or did not do
but Roddy Bryant certainly was not aware
of any such intention and certainly
could not be a party to the crime of
malice murder because he can't
intentionally help commit a crime he
doesn't know is underway doesn't know is
contemplated
at this point we're going to try and go
back and play the video again the the
famous video but I'm going to repeat the
three questions that I started with
when did Roddy Brian know that
McMichaels brought guns with them when
did Ronnie Bryan Know Travis McMichael
would shoot Mr Arbury and at what point
what at that point rather what could
Roddy Brian do to stop it
we ready
I'm gonna try and keep up with this
video
at .03 seconds into this video Mr Arbury
turns around on Halls
well I don't know about this just to be
careful I'm going to pull away from it
for a bit I just don't know what they're
gonna show
gotta be very careful
is
not so much look at the video at this
point
listen with your ears
to the noises in the background
because they tell you what's really
going on even when what you see on the
screen is unclear okay
and we're going to listen to it before
you'll hear Roddy Brian tap the brakes
he's still in Drive
and you'll see he's going at
approximately two miles per hour
okay
yeah let's try that again
looks like they're just repeating this
over and over again very difficult to
get this video precise
but yes we're looking for
four seconds
we're looking for this feed on the
speedometer
[Music]
this is a board of
[Music]
they just went over they're trying to
get the speedometer at two I guess
okay well what you can see is that
Mr Brian is you hear him tap the brakes
you hear Mr Brian tap his brakes
but he's still in drive and he's going
about two miles per hour which is about
the same speed that Mr Arbury is moving
he's been described as chasing Mr Arbury
as hunting Mr Arbury that's attempting
to run Mr r-berry down
but what you see on the video and there
is the the you can see that Mr Brian is
moving at approximately two miles an
hour and you can see that the seat belt
is not in place
now at this point we're going to go
ahead and play it to about the 17 second
mark
listen for the for the gear shifts I'm
sorry it's not there yet go ahead
you should see Mr Bryant's foot is not
on the gas pedal
Obama now you hear a motor vehicle go by
we can guess which vehicle that is
but we hear it pass
and then at 20 seconds we're going to
hear the seat belt alarm go off
at 26 seconds
you can hear the transmission shift
as Mr Brian puts his truck in park
and then two seconds later you'll hear
Mr Brian Buckle his seat belt
please proceed captain
now in about 30 seconds and I'm going to
go through this with you before we play
it so you'll know what to listen for
Mr Brian utters the famous words I'm
gonna keep going
and you'll notice that his cell phone is
down this is where he says I'm going to
keep going
and the state
is suggesting to you if I recall the
opening statement in the opening portion
today that this is where Mr Brian is
turning around to give Chase to Mr Arbor
in the moment before his death
but if you listen carefully I think
you'll hear a somewhat different
story and a different truth
Mr Brian says I'm going to keep going
he's put the car in gear
but if you watch you'll see Mr Brian
isn't going back towards Mr Arbury he's
not going back towards the McMichaels
he's going in the opposite direction he
starts at a high rate of speed
[Music]
what
now you can't see yet
but he's not moving towards Mr Arbury
he's moving away and you'll see why in a
moment
now here you can see the speedometer is
at this point he's slowed back down he's
at four miles an hour at the 51 second
mark
and shortly after this you hear him put
the shift the transmission again
and I think you'll see it's clear from
the context which is a k term
that he is putting the truck into
reverse and then a few seconds later he
puts it back into drive this is the K
turn near the top of holes that you see
on the reenactment video top of homes
near Zellwood go ahead
what is wrong with this lawyer
foreign
it's a team project here we start the
video up
listen for Mr Brian's breathing
I think when you hear his breathing you
will hear something different than the
state has suggested now I can't tell you
how to interpret it
but what I hear
is someone who is labored breathing
breathing as if he was in fear
also around the same time watch Mr
Brian's leg which is it speculative to
describe fear on the basis of breathing
that you claim to hear that Mr Brian's
leg is literally shaking
now
you know he's not driving a Cadillac I'm
sure there's vibration in the vehicle
but if you watch his leg in relation to
the rest of the car to the rest of the
truck I think you'll agree that Mr Brian
at this point is shaking
all right let's try that again
I don't know
did we play the right portion there
doing this okay all right
at this point Roddy Ryan is looking down
back down Holmes
now what does he do here he's pulled up
his cell phone his cell phone's been
down because he was driving away when Mr
Brian
said that he was going home when he said
the guy didn't want to be caught that's
all consistent with this video
now we can see that he's turned around
the question is ladies and gentlemen why
is he turning around
technically this is the shorter path
back to his house
it may be easier to get in the driveway
you can see the bushes and the uh
Maybe
maybe he's trying to document what's
going on he said that's what he was
trying to do
Maybe
and that's just me going out on a limb
I'm going to suggest to you
that perhaps
and I know I'll get grief for this
I would submit to you that you can call
it karma you can call it fate I would
call it Divine Providence well somebody
is guiding Mr Brian whether it's a
conscious thought process or not
something is guiding Mr Brian down this
street to document what's going on
Divine Providence
just like Mr Brian's on his porch why
does he go out he doesn't know he gets
in his car he sits out there he doesn't
even know why
he's being guided whether that's by a
God if you believe in a God or by some
other entity oh my God but do you really
believe it's just coincidence or chance
do you really believe Mr Brian is trying
to lie or deceive you at this point
but we're going to go ahead we're going
to continue playing the video
for you
all right now I think we're gonna I
think now is when we have to cut away
the time is traveling okay as he
testified as a agent indicated in the
reenacting video he's traveling at 10 or
15 miles an hour he's traveling faster
than Mr Arbury but clearly if he was
trying to hunt him down
he would be going a lot faster more to
the point at this point
as Mr Brian comes around the dog leg
what we're seeing here I can't be sure
whether this is the enhanced video or
not uh oh pinch and zoom what we're
seeing here in this courtroom with the
artificial interior lighting is
certainly a better view than Mr Brian
has actually looking through that phone
with the glare and other stuff that's
going to be in the car on a sunny day
anyone who's tried to look at pictures
on their phone while they're driving
on a day like this
understands that sometimes you can't see
the phone at all but assuming that Mr
Brian has 20 20 vision and assuming that
he has every bit as good a view of his
phone as he's driving as you see here
where's Travis McMichael
I can't see Travis McMichael in this
picture
really honestly I can't see great with
Michael in this picture and I certainly
can't see any guns now let's start
what's our post on this one versus
this is at 1 15 into a minute and 43
second video
and Mr Brian at this point has no reason
to know that the individuals in that
truck have guns
all right let's
all right so I believe this is the the
part we're not supposed to show so we'll
we'll cut away for a moment you can
still at this point I think you can see
that there's a shadow
silhouette of what Travis McMichael but
from where Mr Mr Brian is in his vehicle
again even if he has a perfect view of
his phone
you can't see a weapon
you can't see anybody's armed all right
we're going to go forward again
at 1 15. now
what you see the Mr Brian's phone is
focused to the right of the truck why
because Roddy Brian doesn't know Matt Al
benzi is down on Jones at 220 Satilla
with his phone at his gun
the McMichaels know because Mr albenzi
is giving them the hand signal Mr Arbury
knows because he's run out of the house
away from Mr Robinson but Roddy Brian
doesn't know that Roddy Ryan is thinking
that Mr Arbury like he has for the last
minute or so that he's been out there
then Mr Aubry is just going to go around
the truck like he's gone around the
trucks the whole time and head out
Satilla towards the exit to the
neighborhood
all right go ahead again
all right we're all being very careful
very professional 116.
Travis will let you come in view that's
Greg McMichael
where we passed that okay now there's
great big Michael in the back of the
truck
now we know that he has a gun
I think at this point he's on the cell
phone
but I for Mr Roddy Brian's Vantage Point
looking through this phone as he's
trying to drive on a sunny day in his
truck
how can Mr Brian know that Greg
McMichael has a gun
or that he's drawn it
he can't
say
cephahide to
121 place to 121. all right we're being
very very careful here
[Music]
all right this is 121.
you can see Mr arberry you can see how
far back Mr Brian is
and you can see Mr Arbury
going to the left momentarily and way
over here and I will I promise not to
touch the screen
this little
fuzzy black thing here
this silhouette is Travis McMichael
where on this video putting aside the
fact that Mr Brian's not going to have
as good of you driving on a sunny day in
his car from this video alone
where is Mr Travis McMichael's shotgun
Roddy Brian can't see any weapon
he has no reason to know that these men
are armed
and at this point there's 20 seconds
left in this video and we're just going
to go ahead and play it and you tell me
okay in your mind because you can't tell
me figure out when Roddy Brian can see
Travis McMichael's shotgun careful here
because Roddy's looking the wrong way
he's looking to the right expecting his
army to run off oh my God
wow we're now what where are we on the
timestamp
we're now at 128.
body Brian
has never seen and I don't care what is
in any prior statement we know looking
at this video
Ronnie Bryant's never seen the shotgun
until after it's been discharged the
first time
that's not an opinion that's fat you're
looking at it you just never looked at
it from this perspective before
let's go ahead and play the rest of it
this is edgy
wow
now again oh I already had it there
having looked at the video again slowly
oh okay we're Mr Ryan's perspective when
did Roddy Brian know the McMichaels
brought guns
I would submit to you that Mr Brian
doesn't know that there's a gun
until it goes off
not because it wasn't there but you see
what Mr Brian is seeing
when did Roddy Ryan Know Travis would
shoot Mr Arbury
I would submit to you he can't know
until Mr Arbury is actually shot
and at that point what could Roddy Brian
do to stop this tragic shooting
state has thrown out all kinds of
theories he could have honked his horn
he could have gone to the left he could
have gone to the right he should have
backed up well obviously if Mr Brian saw
a shotgun pointing down the street in
his Direction he probably would have at
least ducked
but he doesn't do that because Roddy
Brian can't see the gun
and when the state tells you that he was
hunting Mr auberry down
what they're trying to tell you is that
he's going down the road towards them
when he's going up the road away from
them
and when he says he turns around
he brings the video back up he takes the
best video that we have the only video
we have of this shooting
so when Mr Bryant says on the side of
the road on February 23rd the officer
minshu
I was trying to record what happened I
don't know what I got I think I got two
or three he only got one
but fortunately
he got the one that you need
to figure out
what Justice is in this case and again
it's not for Roddy Brian it's not for me
to say what Justice is here between the
McMichaels and Mr Aubrey and his family
that's not our call that's your call
but again but for Mr Brian whether you
call it serendipity
luck coincidence
or the hand of God here not once but
twice as someone who keeps to themselves
who never gets involved in anybody
else's business who is almost a stranger
in his own neighborhood has now gone out
and gotten a video
which is the best evidence for you to
look at and trying to figure out what
happened here
now is going to come up in different
contexts but the judge is going to
struck you on the principle of
abandonment
and it has more than one application
here but basically if somebody abandons
a criminal Enterprise
then they cannot be held criminally
responsible for it
maybe you believe that Mr Brian was
attempting to imprison
falsely imprisoned Mr Aubry of course
that would depend on whether or not the
McMichaels were authorized to make a
citizen's arrest we'll talk more about
those issues later but
this is a defense and it is the burden
of the state to disprove that defense
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
under the facts of this case from this
video as we've just gone through it
how could anyone say Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt
then Mr Brian
having turned away
that he didn't come back for the right
reasons
how can one say that he's lied on
February 23rd when he says he was trying
to get a recording of Mr Arbor that he
was trying to document what was going on
because he thought Mr Arbury was going
to get away and he wanted the police to
have that information those aren't my
words those are his words way back
moments after the shooting
and I haven't seen that Mr Brian
was going away and then turned around
and put the video back up
how is that not a reasonable doubt in
this case
now
I don't know what Miss dunakowski is
going to say to mccowski I'm sorry is
going to say when she gets back up here
I do know that it seems like every
technician in creation has been involved
in this case drone this footage that
filter this enhance that pinch and zoom
we got 20 million frames of every second
of the footage in this case but how in
the course of all that work
does someone who's practically computer
illiterate
figure out that they have this case all
wrong uncharged piccolos how is that
possible and how do you know that count
the gear shifts ladies and gentlemen the
state's theory is that there's
three shifts three changes in Direction
that's six gear shifts
they're not audible we know what
happened and I don't care what Travis
McMichael says I don't care what anybody
else says I'm looking at the video and
I'm listening for the changes you know
that when this right here when Mr Arbury
turns around and whatever Mr Brian
thinks he's doing with the wheel I don't
see much actual movement okay actually
in the two miles an hour and then his
foot's off the gas pedal
whatever Mr Brian thinks he did
I don't think it was much but
you know that he's driving away from Mr
Aubry at this point because he can't go
back and then go back and then go back
again because there aren't enough gear
shifts
all right I think we're done with that
one
I want to talk to you about felony
murder oh my God
now there are more capable lawyers than
I in this courtroom and they certainly
have come up with great ways to analyze
all these things and make it simple I'm
just not quite as as
Adept that they are
so if I take a little longer I apologize
oh my God the predicate offenses for the
felony murder counts those are counts
two three four and five or count six
seven eight and nine and I will address
each of the underlying or predicate
felonies in a moment but right now I
want to talk about something called
proximate cause
because to support any of the felony
murder counts in this case there has to
be a causal relationship to the death of
a mod artery and there is no such
relationship in this case
without trying to put words in the
Court's mouth
uh I think the Court's going to charge
you I'm not there yet you may find the
defendant guilty of felony murder if you
believe that Mr Brian caused the death
of Mr Arbury regardless of whether Mr
Bryant intended the death to occur
that's felony murder there must be some
causal connection between the felony and
the death
the court I believe will instruct you
that felony murder is not established
simply because the death occurred at the
same time or shortly after the felony
was attempted or committed the burden on
the state is much greater the felony
must have been
directly caused or must have directly
caused to death or played both a
substantial and necessary part in
causing the death
in this case you may also consider
whether any intervening act those are my
words whether on the part of the
McMichaels or Mr Arbor we're sufficient
to break the causal chain of events
Mr actually I believe both of the
lawyers have preceded me from the
McMichael defendants have pointed out
the error in the state's argument here
listen carefully the Court's charge the
words but for up here nowhere in that
charge
they are not to be found
why because but 4 is not the standard
it's too easy a standard it's too low a
standard it doesn't meet the law why
Mr Sheffield pointed out that but for oh
no I think Mr Travis McMichael's
grandparents
Travis McMichael wouldn't have been
there
likewise I would say but for Roddy
Brian's birth there's no way that this
crime could have taken place under the
state's reasoning
you know the same thing could be said
but for Larry English installing
surveillance cameras to McMichaels would
never have known that this was the
fellow running by them but for Matt Al
benzi pulling out his wood chipper that
day chipping in the front yard he never
would have saw Mr Arbury but for the
actions of Robert rash and Diego Perez
this incident might not have happened
but for Mr valbenzi calling the normal
police number instead of 9-1-1
the police might have responded faster
and things might have been different
but for Mr albenzi cutting off the
Satilla Drive exit Mr Aubry might have
escaped but for a hundred different
things
all of which had to come together in the
exact sequence for this tragedy to take
place it could not have happened
so simply saying that but for Mr Brian
being there that day that's not the
standard and the state doesn't even try
and meet the standard that the court is
going to instruct you on
and maybe they're just waiting until
they have the last word and all I can
say about that
is that's just dirty pool and I
certainly hope that's not what's going
on
now again with all respect to the state
who has some very capable lawyers
when we look objectively at the events
of February 23rd
I would respectfully submit to you that
Roddy Brian's presence is absolutely
superfluous
and irrelevant
to the tragic death of a mod Arbor
now that may not be intuitively obvious
but if you think about it I believe
you'll agree
had Roddy Brian stayed in bed that day
if Roddy Bryant had stayed on his front
porch
would a mod arbory be alive today
this if the state's theory is that these
men and I'm not saying that's the case
you decide what what the deal is about
co-defense he's kind of throwing the
other defendants under the bus I like it
Vigilantes have Harvard some ill will
towards
Mr Arbury then what difference does it
make with a Roddy Brian is there wow
Mr Arbury can't outrun bullets
they've been chasing him for for a while
and he's it practically Point Blank
Range even before he comes around the
truck
the problem is for the state that Mr
al-benzi thankfully not indicted not yet
anyway
Mr albenzi is down the street with his
firearm
Roddy Ryan doesn't know that that's why
Roddy Brian goes down
Satilla momentarily as Mr Brian is
turning up the road you'll remember the
testimony where the state was trying to
say that Mr Brian was trying to run him
over when in fact Mr Harvey who's had
already turned up homes by the time Mr
Brian put his car in Reverse one of them
several times they incorrectly stated he
was trying to run Mr Arbury over the
reason that Mr Brian is continuing to
answer Tila is he doesn't know that Mr
albenzi is there he can't variety that
Mr Army does which is why Mr Arbor is
not going to go down that way now my
point to you is
Mr Arbury is on foot
the McMichaels are in a pickup truck
we know they circle around all the way
up Zellwood to the top of homes
how does Mr Brian's presence on the road
that day
whatever he thought he was doing okay
because if the idea is that he
imprisoned Mr Aubry by himself that
somehow
and those are the words he uses that he
cornered Mr Arbury by himself I guess
between his truck and the mailbox I
don't know between struck in the marsh
I don't know the state will have to
explain the theory to you but
the truck can go a lot faster Mr Arbury
if he's superhuman
I'd be doing five or six miles an hour
maybe seven
that pickup truck is capable of probably
driving 100 miles an hour superhuman is
seven miles an hour has this guy ever
been to a gym on the road
has nothing to do with the ability of
the McMichael defendants to cut Mr
Arbury off why because even though Roddy
Ryan doesn't know it now Lindsay's cut
off one of the two exits from the
neighborhood and the McMichaels are
already at the top of homes they've cut
off the set six to seven is just a basic
jog Brian is not trapping Mr Arbury
he's trapped the moment the McMichaels
get to the top of homes it doesn't
really matter what Roddy does now they
do come down the road and there is a
brief time period before the shooting
where technically Mr Brian is behind Mr
Arbury but it's clear by this point it's
certainly clear to Mr Arbury that he
cannot outrun the McMichaels no matter
where he goes they can follow
so again how is Mr Brian's presence on
this day in any meaningful way because
of this shooting
and by the time Mr Brian gets around the
dog leg
Mr Arbury is already well within range
of the shotgun that Travis McMichael is
holding and the handgun that Gregory
McMichael has so if their intention and
again I'm not suggesting that it's their
intention
but if we make Michael's meant harm to
Mr Arbury if they meant to shoot him
that day
what in the world is Mr Brian's presence
out there have to do with anything
I would submit to you that this is
basically all the smoke screen from the
state because Mr Brian's presence
doesn't contribute in a direct or
substantial way to the death of Mr
Arbury yeah basically this guy isn't
smart enough athletic enough
or aware enough to have been involved in
the crime
thank you
foreign
cause issue I want to discuss on these
four felony murder counts because it's
basically the same issue
and the issue the principle is one of
intervening Acts
the judge is going to instruct you that
it must that the causation must be
direct and it must be substantial
and although the charge doesn't use the
words essentially it must be unbroken
anything that breaks the chain of
causation
prevents a return of a verdict on felony
murder
I mean that is
um Mr golf if we could please
if you were going to make representation
with regard to the law that will be
charged to the jury yes we could remain
within the charge that has already been
approved by the court and that will be
read by the court
let me uh thank you
oh man
let me go back and make sure I haven't
misspoken
it actually would be reasonable for the
judge here to say how much longer do you
plan to go on off the death or played a
substantial and necessary part in
causing the death
in this case what I'm suggesting to you
is that if either the actions of Mr
Arbury
or the actions of Travis McMichael or
the actions of both
contributed to Mr arbury's death
then Mr Brian cannot be the direct the
substantial and the necessary cause of
that death right what am I talking about
that's what we want to know I think it's
already been referenced I could be wrong
I don't want to misspeak
that Travis I'm sorry that Ahmad Arbury
turns in front of the vehicle at the
last the the white pickup truck at the
last moment and basically meets Travis
McMichael in the front of the truck we
can't
see in front of the truck but we know
that's where they are
a question for you is and I'm not trying
to decipher who did water why
because from Mr Brian's perspective it
doesn't matter it does for yours but for
Mr Brian's perspective it doesn't matter
but
Mr arbury's decision at that last moment
to turn left instead of right as Mr
Brian would have expected as you can
tell from the way he's angling his phone
anticipating Mr arbory's path of travel
when Mr Arbury turns to the left
does that not break the causal chain in
this case
I would submit that it does
whether Mr Arbury is Justified
in turning and coming at Mr McMichael or
not
that's for you to decide that affects
other people in this case
but Mr Brian is not responsible for that
that breaks the chain the causal chain
is no longer substantial and necessary
it's no longer direct likewise
when Mr Travis McMichael
closes the distance
from to the left of the truck as you're
looking at it on the screen towards the
middle of the truck or exactly where
I'll let you all figure that out
but when Travis McMichael does that
regardless of whether Travis McMichael
is Justified in doing so
doesn't that also break the direct
causation does it not also break the
substantial and necessary part of Mr
Brian
and causing the death
of Mr Arbury I would submit to you that
Mr Brian cannot be
the direct and substantial and necessary
cause of Mr arberry's death
whether that is the fault for lack of a
better phrase of Mr McMichael the fault
of Mr Arbury or the fault of both
or simply
throughout without any fault on either
part in unavoidable tragedy
why should Roddy Brian be held
responsible for that I would submit to
you under a law Mr Brian it cannot be
guilty of any of the felony murder
counts
for that reason all out
all right we're gonna count six
oh my God count six alleges uh
aggravated assault by shooting
we know that Roddy Brian did not shoot
Mr Armory
the theory here is parties to a crime
and again how can Mr Brian intentionally
help commit a crime that he has no
reason to believe is about to take place
when did Mr Brian see the gun when does
Mr Brian know they're armed at what
point what at that point what can Mr
Brian do about it again you've seen from
the video that by the time Mr Brian
knows that the McMichaels are armed it's
mere seconds before the shooting tank
takes place so the idea that Mr Brian's
going to get out of his car or a hawk or
yell stop
we know that's that's Fantasy on the
part of the state what's going to happen
is going to happen at that point
Mr Brian cannot be guilty as a part of
the crime because he can't intentionally
help commit a crime he doesn't have
reason to believe is going to take place
and he doesn't help
the McMichaels could have shot Mr Arbury
had that been their intention to
McMichaels could have shot Mr Arbury
before he got to Roddy Brian's driveway
they could have done it the whole time
that's got nothing to do with Roddy
Bryant
they don't need Roddy Brian's help to
shoot this young man
and I'm again I'm not implying guilt or
innocence here it's not my call it's
your call for the other defendants but
what does that have to do with Mr Brian
that takes us back to aggravated assault
count seven
I've discussed the physical evidence
with you before the lack thereof and I'm
going to go through that just as quickly
as I can I would note that the state
presented no rebuttal evidence
uh during the trial of the case and so
the evidence is the same as it was when
we first had this conversation
I would submit to you that Ronnie Bryan
is an out there like Evil Knievel
tearing up his neighbor's yards how do
we know that first where are the
pictures of the Damage Done by his truck
tires there's no evidence of that second
there's no evidence neighbors complained
of reported destruction there's no
evidence of landscaping material or
other material on the underside of his
truck how could this be with a deep
perhaps watery drain I think the
evidence was conflicting drainage ditch
running along much of Burford
again the context is key I believe
Council for one of the McMichaels
pointed the same thing out basically how
hard can it be when they didn't elude
someone who can't go off-road without
doing more damage
then the neighbors would allow
there's no evidence from the truck's
computer system Roddy Brian again is
either the smartest guy in the room
or I guess he's just the luckiest guy in
the world because when he speaks to
minshua on the scene and later Lowry
detective Lara that Sunday afternoon
he has no way of knowing whether that
information has or will be preserved
there's no let nor is there any evidence
that Roddy Brian tampered with it
certainly you can't blame him that law
enforcement wait several months to
pursue that evidence
there's no evidence that Mr Brian
deleted or edited the video from 223
that we know he couldn't practically
speaking he watched it at the same time
as a police officer
where is the physical evidence on the
roadway of Mr Brian's aggressive driving
where are the tire tracks the brake
marks the skid marks for all the times
Mr Brian supposedly has stopped short or
changed Direction so that it doesn't
destroy anything
there's simply no physical evidence of
aggressive driving
what about the lumber in the back of the
truck
you know the evidence shows it's still
in the back of his truck afterwards
there's no evidence that any of those
Timbers went through the back of his
windshield no evidence Mr Brian had to
drive back around the neighborhood
picking them up
no evidence of damage to the bed line of
a tailgate I don't believe there's
evidence of even a scratch attributed to
all the acrobatic Maneuvers implied by
the state
I'm not sure there's even a picture of
the front of Mr Ryan's truck in evidence
but if there is I'm sure miss donatoski
will provide it for you
nobody's been looking for that evidence
because
there was no crime to investigate
there are no Witnesses nobody will
testify if they saw Mr Brian Drive
aggressively or recklessly no neighbors
will testify to that because it didn't
happen we have a neighborhood chock full
of security videos none of them catch
this aggressive driving
what is the medical examiner tell us the
medical examiner testified extensively
in this trial he testified I believe
that the pickup truck could be a deadly
weapon depending on the manner which it
was used and that's consistent with the
charge this court is going to give you
but what evidence is there that Mr Brian
did in fact
injure Mr Arbury
I don't recall there being any testimony
of any physical injuries to Mr Arbury
attributable to Mr Brian's actions the
cause of death
was gunshot
let's talk about the fingerprint
evidence for a moment the fingerprint or
palm print is at this driver's side door
on the side of the pickup truck
Mr Brian points this out in the minutes
after the shooting to officer minshu
there are no prints or cotton fibers in
the front on the front of the truck or
on the back of the truck
now last I checked unless you're a
Hollywood stunt person maybe a veteran
who fasted Furious Tokyo Drift you're
not in control unless you're out of
control I think that was the trailer for
the movie absent something extraordinary
like that we know the pickup trucks
don't move sideways
we also know when I said earlier there
was no witness
we have a witness and that's Travis
McMichael Travis McMichael testified
about the events of 2 23 20. Travis
McMichael did not testify to aggressive
driving on the part of Roddy Bryant
Travis McMichael testified I believe to
Mr Arbury attempting to getting Roddy
Brian's vehicle not once but twice
carjacking is a felony attempted
carjacking is a felony you will be
charged on what attempt is
um but the point here is that the
objective evidence is not that Mr Brian
was engaged in aggressive behavior the
evidence is
that Mr Arbury was
and I don't say that as a measure of
disrespect to Mr Arbury that's just what
the testimony is
um and
I think the state questioned that that
could be wrong but if I could remind the
jury I believe during the testimony of a
special agent Jason Seacrest
during that testimony I believe I
specifically referenced page 54 of that
transcript
there's a there's a time they were
writing by Brian is testifying and he
says he's coming back at me and I'm like
Oh blank excuse me again
and I started a kind of evasive action
which we see on the video and drop the
phone
so
long before Mr Ryan has any reason to
believe that anybody else has seen this
he's provided that information
getting back to Mr Brian's statements as
I've indicated before context is the key
it's not what the words Mr Brian's using
it's the truth the meaning that he's
attempting to convey with him and I
think I may have used the example before
if I were to say I ran into your ex
in the parking lot at Walmart you
wouldn't assume I ran them over although
technically you could interpret the
words that way there are a lot of words
that we use when we talk on this coming
weekend when Bulldog fans talk about
wrecking Tech
we don't actually expect that they will
it's a figure of speech
and again and again through the
examination of these officers we see
that the words that the state has taken
have been taken out of context we see
that they've been juxtaposed in
inappropriate ways to suggest a
conversation that was different than it
was
but I can tell you remember this
discussion previously so I'm going to
truncate that discussion by pointing out
the obvious
three police officers interview Roddy
Bryant
they don't mirandize him
they don't tell them that he's under
investigation because he's not at the
time of all these interviews Roddy Brian
is a witness
at the conclusion of the Glenn County
Police Department report Roddy Brian is
still a witness
Roddy Brian may not be careful with his
words because Roddy Grimes never been
told anybody's looking at him
but the bottom line is this three good
solid police officers that you heard
testify I'll interview Mr Pride all of
them write written summaries of their
reports I think I went through the five
page version of Mr Secrets I think I
went through the versions of the other
officers not the transcripts but their
actual summaries three police officers
who know exactly what they're doing
interview Mr Brian none of them
interpret his word to suggest that he
committed an aggravated assault none of
them interpreted his words to suggest
that he was involved in any false
imprisonment none of them read none of
them hear that in what he says and I
would humbly suggest to you that if
three police officers interview Mr
Bryant for what turns out to be a total
of hours okay you remember we had an
argument about how long the transcripts
were and what that would mean
I don't care how you break it down three
experienced police officer interviewed
Ryan none of them summarized for their
superiors that Mr Ryan attempted to run
over Mr harbury attempt to distract Mr
Arbor you're attempted to imprison Mr
Arbury it's not there
and if that isn't a reasonable doubt on
count seven aggravated assault I just
don't know what it would be
before I leave count seven
I do want to discuss lesser offenses
I'm not really sure why we call them
lesser offenses but that's what we call
them
with respect to the aggravated assault
count with respect to Mr Brian only
the court is going to charge you on
three lesser offenses two of them are
pretty much Garden variety one of them
is a traffic fence we'll leave those for
your consideration the third one I do
want to discuss however
that is reckless conduct we don't see
that one as often so let me take a
minute and discuss that
reckless in Reckless conduct that
offense is committed when a person
commits Reckless conduct when that
person endangers the bodily safety of
another person person they consciously
disregarding a substantial and
unjustifiable risk that his act or
Omission will cause harm or endanger the
safety of the other person
and the disregard constitutes a gross
deviation from the standard of care
which a reasonable person would exercise
I would suggest to you that Mr Brian did
not
consciously disregard a substantial
unjustifiable risk
in operating his motor vehicle we would
submit to you that Mr Brian did not
commit any offense in the operation of
his motor vehicle but this is before you
and if you decide
that you believe Mr Brian's guilty of
that then Mr Brian will have to live
with the consequences
we have two counts left and
your honor
I'm getting a look uh and I don't know
whether that means
I think the jury might want to break
it's there that's up to them
head shaking no okay well then that's
the answer I sometimes when people are
shaking their heads you don't know what
they mean all right
dear God sometimes people are shaking
their heads yeah he's crazy I get it all
right let's talk a little bit about
following Christmas
Mr Brian never denied following Mr
Harvey Mr Brian has never denied quote
unquote angling his vehicle ahead of Mr
Arbury although he did not use the words
in the first interview as the state had
suggested he did use that word
subsequently Mr Brian's never denied
blocking Mr arberry's path to travel
he's never denied cutting in ahead of Mr
Arbury he's admitted that he did that
several times but as to exactly how many
times or where or when I believe the
state acknowledged in their opening that
they really didn't know the path to
travel is essentially speculation
but what we've shown you I think at this
point is that although Mr Brian did all
those things
that's not a false imprisonment
among other things Mr Bryant with his
own vehicle can't do that on his own and
we know that the McMichael vehicle has
gone back down till it to Zellwood and
all the way around which is why Mr
Arbury is alone there for key parts of
this encounter
all right
the court will charge you on the law
with respect to false imprisonment this
is count eight
I think Michael attorneys have already
gone over this in some detail I'll try
to avoid that same ground
first where there is no confinement no
detention there can be no false
imprisonment
That's the Law free Basin Mr Arbury
never really stopped he never submitted
I think the state's position was that Mr
opening was it Mr Arbury resisted to the
end of his life
and in saying that I need no disrespect
to mount arbory I do not wish in any way
to lessen the magnitude of this tragedy
I'm simply applying the relevant lot of
the facts
I'm going to use a different example to
kind of illustrate the point I'm trying
to make
I try to be humorous sometimes sometimes
the humor is not successful if it's not
please don't hold it against Mr Brian to
illustrate the point I'm trying to make
here let us consider the classic example
of a bank robbery okay a man with a gun
enters the bank and yells with a gun
yells get down on the ground
I will shoot there are three customers
in the bank the first is a lawyer the
second is a school teacher the third is
a college freshman listening to music
texting a girl and late for class
now
instead of getting on the ground and
before the robber can even finish his
thought the lawyer foolishly asks hey
don't I know you
the lawyer gets shot
he instantly dies
this is murder or felony murder
however this is not false imprisonment
the second customer the school teacher
says please don't shoot me I have
children I'm taking a busload of kids to
the museum
she gets on the ground
the school teacher has complied with the
robber's commands she's shaken but
otherwise okay the school teacher she
has been falsely imprisoned
the Third customer the college freshman
for whatever reason ignores the bank
robber the college freshman says nothing
but runs out the door just as fast as he
can he never looks back when his parents
call later that day asking how he's
doing the college freshman doesn't even
mention his near-death experience
the college freshmen although certainly
fortunate to be alive has not been
falsely imprisoned likewise in the case
before us under Georgia law I would
respectfully submit to you whatever
other crimes may have been committed
that day Mr Arbury was not falsely
imprisoned prior to his tragic death
you may see things differently for
reasons that should soon be clear she
may contend remember under Georgia law
she always gets the last word that Mr
artery did somehow submit in the last
moments of his life to a combination of
the harsh verbal commands of the
McMichael defendants if they did so and
the brandishment of the shotgun if that
happened that's not exactly the way I
recall the evidence but I would submit
that there's still no false imprisonment
here as a matter of law
that I
please look more carefully at count
eight Mr Brian is not charged with
falsely imprisoning Mr Arbury with
either verbal commands or guns
that is not how the indictment reads it
alleges that Mr Arbury was confined and
detained quote unquote using said pickup
trucks
the Cobb County District Attorney
I would suggest that you should hold
them to that language
nor just count eight alleged to Mr
Arbury was falsely imprisoned on Burford
count nine alleges an attempt to commit
false imprisonment on Burford we'll come
back to that
count eight
does not allege that Mr Aubry was
falsely imprisoned on Burford
now that may be where the state contends
to chase started but the indictment
alleges the false imprisonment pickup
trucks happened on homes the state
contends that what you see on the now
that's what the state continues to see
on the now famous video we'll come back
to that there are other several legal
principles we should review before he's
still coming back to stuff discuss this
amendment is a defense to the charge of
false imprisonment and I think I've been
through that so I won't torture you with
that again
foreign
this is this is brutal it really is
by the way someone put this together and
I like it very much from earlier today
it's pretty solid things I've already
covered I'm not going to repeat for you
all right trying to find
that's my Garfield comics
we've covered that thanks to Kathy
Fleming for signing up on my website
joinpakman.com Kathy's new member number
74 today
we have a new coupon code
obamna is the code Obama count nine
Roddy Brian is charged with attempted
false imprisonment on Burford Drive
he's not charged with attempted false
imprisonment on Holmes only birth
there are reasons for that but they're
really not relevant to this discussion
the court will charge you that in order
to commit the crime of criminal attempt
commit false imprisonment the state must
prove intent to commit false
imprisonment
because that's required to be a party to
the crime in other words to prove an
attempt which is what is known as an
incoa crime the state must show Mr
Brian's specific intent to falsely
imprison Harvey in other words
for the attempt charge Mr Brian would
have to know that the McMichaels with
whom he had not spoken lacked probable
cause
now whether you ultimately determine
that the McMichaels had probable cause
or that Mr Brian had it on his own there
obviously was some considerable
testimony about his trailer being taken
some something taken out of family
member's truck
he had indicated he got the security
system because of concerns he'd heard a
bunch of stuff at work but specifically
with respect to the McMichaels because
he's not spoken to me Michael's he can't
have the specific intent
to help them falsely in
falsely imprisoned Mr Arbury
it's just a quirk of the law that
he doesn't he can't be convicted on that
basis
now
almost done
when I go home this evening I want 74
Sinclair I will be sleeping soundly for
the first time in a while
because this case hopefully will be if
we have been submitted to you by then
and my work will be done Miss
dunnakowski is going to get the last
word
I ask yourself to ask the questions that
I will not be able to
please don't allow any more cheap shots
no more gotcha moments in this case
you will recall the state I believe that
was Miss dunnakowski playing the video
of a utility truck stopping at the
English residence and the guy jumps out
to use the porta potty
which was relevant to absolutely nothing
other than this done akowski's desire to
reinforce for you the fact that Mr
Arbury was dead that was clearly
inappropriate it was what I call a
gotcha moment and I would submit there's
already been too much of it why did he
give his address anybody know coming
here trying to tell you who you should
believe again please no more cheap shots
in closing and then of course we have
the state talking about the death
penalty for theft for which they were
admonished by the court
and I'm not trying to rub it in but I
would suggest to you that given all of
the cheap shots and all the
misstatements
I won't say they're knowing we won't be
jumping any assumptions but given all
the cheap shots in this case against Mr
bride I would hope
that when Miss done akoski has the last
word here that you will hold her
accountable
and that you will not accept or tolerate
any more cheap shots when I have no
opportunity to respond
again I'm going to posit these three
questions to you oh my god when did
Roddy Ryan know the McMichaels brought
guns
when did Roddy Ryan Know Travis
McMichael would shoot Mr Arbury
and at that point what could Roddy
Bryant possibly have done to stop him
Mr Brian put his faith in the Glenn
County Police Department
and then he put his faith in the gbi
he put his trust in law enforcement he
put his trust in our government
to do the right thing by him
his trust was not rewarded and now he
finds himself before you
we place Roddy Ryan's fate in your hands
we ask you to return a verdict of not
guilty on all counts
I ask you to send Roddy Brian home thank
you
wow
a never-ending closing statement
from the guy concerned about too many
black Pastors in the room
all right thanks Council all right
ladies and gentlemen we are going to
take a 15-minute recess we need to work
through some scheduling issues and
figure out where we are and um we will
bring you back out for a continuation of
the case or other announcements uh in
about 15 minutes thank you all right
everything
I do want to say thank you to so many
people who have welcomed us back to
Twitch after our 11-day suspension
uh those people include let me make sure
I get everybody here
blueberry babe half cabbage another
blueberry gave two uh two gifts
some wild poos bone Master nug Wrangler
try killer Eric
Margot Cabot Deb Andrew
glimer girl another gift from blueberry
babe
a bradent CB
almost 4 45. as far as the state's
remainder of closing
yes judge
um I'm gonna take the full two hours I
have way too much talk to wow and to but
given the excellent three closing
arguments uh that were just done by the
defense attorneys
she will take the full two hours
local Council yeah thank you um we're
ready to hear it we're hopeful to hear
in complete closings tonight it seems
like the jury wants to keep going wow
and um we're prepared to stay and listen
attentively and I guess then do charge
in the morning
as well and you said they've been very
actively engaged they do everybody seems
to want to be done before Thanksgiving
12
seemed actually quite attentive yes I
agree
can someone tell me what happened with
juror 12 the juror 12 fall asleep at
some point I don't know the reference
likes or issues with them knowing that
there are two hours potentially of
argument and that they won't get the
case tonight because the court is going
to charge them tomorrow
anybody have any objection
okay
ah okay
we're gonna break things let me break
and um
we'll make that inquiry I'll notify
Council of the result of that inquiry
all right so the judge presiding very
strongly over the case here
uh one of the defense won a juror 12
dismissed for sleeping but prosecution
didn't see it and judge didn't see it
okay
fair fair I want to say thank you to
Luciano Quinones who just signed up on
my website with the coupon code Obama
and his new member number 89 if you're
just joining us today the coupon code
uncharged pickles is done but we have a
new code obamna and I would love it if
you grabbed a membership on my website
joinpakman.com
I also want to say thanks to some great
people over on Twitch we made our
triumphant and defiant return to Twitch
today after an 11 day ban I want to say
thanks to Jay Noble symbolic gamer and
Dilbert 93.
putting us at 92 today now I will not be
streaming this live but we will have a
very very powerful element tomorrow on
the podcast of an audio visual element
of the Tucker Carlson Kyle Rittenhouse
interview a few Clips have been released
and I'm going to play them for you here
let's take a look
I tell everybody there what happened I
said I had to do it I just I was just
attacked I was dizzy I was vomiting I I
couldn't breathe that is one clip that
has been released
oh thanks to Sam gishel for the twitch
Prime sub sending us uh the message
Obama oh
here is the next Tucker Carlson Kyle
Rittenhouse clip full interview is
tonight
this case has nothing to do with race
um it never had anything to do with race
it had to do with the right to
self-defense right
um I'm not a racist person I support the
BLM movement I support peacefully
demonstrating
and I believe there needs to be change I
believe there's a lot of prosecutorial
misconduct not just in my case but in
other cases
and it's just amazing to see
how how much a prosecutor can take
advantage of somebody one of the
funniest things to me about all of this
is that
maybe he feared for his life and maybe
not guilty is the right verdict
but what difference does it make what an
18 year old thinks about this stuff
like he's not
he's he's just a guy who killed two
people he's not
you know I like who who cares
[Music]
um
by the way a lot of right-wingers
triggered that he says he supports BLM
um you can search Twitter and find
apoplectic tweets about he's not one of
us and all this different stuff it's
it's pretty interesting
um here's one more more legal opinion
here from Kyle Rittenhouse
it wasn't Kyle Rittenhouse on trial in
Wisconsin it was the right to
self-defense on trial
and if I was convicted
no one would be able no one would ever
be privileged to defend their life
against attackers it wasn't Kyle Britton
oh man like who who cares it's it's
weird like the real questions are
uh in my mind
his attorney is it Mark Richard Richards
was interviewed the day of the verdict
or the day after and said
Kyle has told me if he could do it over
again he just wouldn't even have gone
his mom said to Sean Hannity if we were
to do it all over again he would have
done the exact same thing
I would hope that Tucker Carlson asks
that question
I don't know if he will
um let's see if there's any other clips
that have been released
I'm guessing it's just those three
self-defense case has nothing to do with
race
yeah it doesn't it seems like those are
the only clips that have been released
which makes sense
uh actually let's just see here on the
Fox News website let's see what this is
about
exclusively to Fox News and her first
interview since her son was acquitted on
all counts in the trial that divided the
country Wendy Rittenhouse describing the
moments she heard the not guilty
verdicts and how the trial has affected
her son and her family hello everyone
and welcome to Fox News Live I'm arthel
Neville hi Eric hi Arthur well everyone
thank you for joining us here on Fox
News Channel this afternoon reaction to
rittenhouse's acquittal continues to
Ripple across our nation Ripple there
have been protests in several cities
ongoing this weekend with police
declaring one in Portland Oregon a riot
lawmakers also weighing in including
house Judiciary chair Jerry and Adler he
calls for the Department of Justice to
review the verdict meantime a car
writtenhouse his mother on what she says
her son is thinking and now feeling
he does have remorse you know and like
if people say if he can do it again he
would I said he would do again but
talking to him now he would never went
down there if this ever happened again
so she's changed her position on that
okay
interesting he will never
more of that exclusive interview at a
moment but first let's go to senior car
spot on Mike Tobin he's live in Kenosha
Wisconsin with the very latest from
there I might all right so there's that
um we're gonna have that tonight I am
curious if we can get a live shot in
Kenosha right now just to see what's
going on
uh Kenosha
and live let's see what we've got here
not clear that there's anything live
happening there at this time
okay so we don't even need to bother
with that that's totally fine
uh it was just more of a curiosity as to
what's going on there so tomorrow we
will um we will review that it's
completely plausible that they've
decided the best possible thing in terms
of the framing for this interview is to
kind of play to the middle play to the
Second Amendment self-defense people
play to the I support BLM stuff
um
and that that might reduce the
temperature the most I don't know
I don't know it's certainly an
interesting question uh and all we can
do is is wait and see tonight that quite
frankly I mean that that's really all
that we can do so we'll be covering that
tomorrow let me get to some super chats
because we've we've been neglecting them
as we've been listening here juror 12
was the last black juror they were
trying to get rid of them by saying they
were sleeping oh my God is that true
what's the time limit on the closing
argument so far has to be close right I
don't know that they established a time
limit but maybe it's two hours per
person which is why the prosecutor there
uh referred to two at the full two hours
this is the Chewbacca defense any update
on when the food will arrive I thought
it was always noon more food around noon
he's repeatedly asked for a mistrial at
this point he's like the soles of my
shoes are black the jury can see them
this warrant a mistrial
was that a Fast and Furious Tokyo Drift
reference
dear God that I don't know I did if it
was I didn't recognize it I don't know
anything about that that's definitely
not an area in which I am well versed
let me get to a few additional
voicemails that have been coming in here
let's take a look
hey David people from Wisconsin
um so if you listen to that interview
earlier where Donald Trump said you know
president has been assaulted is that it
dependent I mean you were laughing at
him you're making seasoning jokes
paprika say seasoning Laurie's
um hey is this voicemail clear to you
guys because to me it sounds completely
muddled
like I it's intelligible but it's it's
it's very very it's not exactly pristine
audio High Fidelity audio it's muffled
for you guys as well okay
starting to wonder if I'm having a
hearing problem here whatever it was and
I just think that's ridiculous I mean
that was obvious no president has been
assaulted the way Donald Trump has not
Abe Lincoln not China Kennedy not Teddy
Roosevelt no nobody's been under assault
or been assault is the way Donald Trump
has so I think that I just wanted to
call and clear that up you know is that
a joke can you guys tell if that's a
joke
very very strange
hey David what's up man it's Brandon
from Connecticut uh just think you'd
find this funny I work in telemarketing
and my name is actually Brandon it would
be recent catchphrase of conservative as
I've actually you know thought about
potentially
going by a pseudonym network but uh yeah
I just thought you guys can you imagine
if people named Brandon are having to
think of changing their name the kick
out of that and I guess uh I know what
it's like to be a Karen now yeah quite
frankly quite frankly
hey David
Dave from California
don't you think it's funny
that Kyle rittenhouse's original lawyers
were just using him
to raise money
and that Fox News
was just using him
because it was going to be a big story
right
and it was only his second team of
lawyers that
this guy is facing murder charges he can
go away forever okay
very very important
hi David uh I had a question on a video
that you posted about uh doing jury duty
uh do you think that having professional
jurors would uh
render like uh more accurate verdicts
uh you know like professional jurors
that are say like trained in the law to
some basic degree and trained in like
forensic science yeah I've talked about
this I think it would solve some
problems but create others
and I think it's I think it's a very
very complicated thing extremely
complicated thing uh but I have
addressed that before
hi David this is Jeff from Colorado
I just uh heard your
uh session on the new Democratic talking
points and I absolutely agree that the
Democrats need to take a more aggressive
um talking
a set of points that will
mobilize its base and I think that it
should be
generally based on facts like
um okay yeah I do agree with that
I do agree with that
hey David uh just under curiosity are
you more of a by the garden uh kind of
guy when it comes or are you more of a
jorjito or Alana
yeah I'm partial to Alana quite frankly
I think you don't be able to look at him
important question important question
foreign
so now we will continue with the
rebuttal
this is going to be quite a quite a
scene I believe
um
not
all right
please proceed governor
two things
first is apparently the group that has
stayed in the front of the courthouse
for the last
five and a half weeks or how long we've
been going
um has started marching around the
courthouse and apparently they just did
one circuit of the courthouse and that's
continuing because of that I've asked
the bailiffs to go ahead and move the
jury from an exterior deliberation room
to an interior deliberation room so
we're going to go ahead and do that just
so that there's no issues
with the the panel and whatever may be
going on outside so that's one two is I
did address the panel uh indicated to
them that the state believed it had
about two hours of argument
that the court would still need to
charge the jury before we got into
deliberations and all probability that
charge would occur tomorrow I left the
room asked that they go ahead and notify
the court uh where they were and the
note that I got back as we would like to
leave oh wow uh based on that I'm going
to go ahead and break for the day wow
we're going to start a little bit
earlier tomorrow so again a little bit
of time so I'm planning to start at 8 30
tomorrow morning I'll start at 8 30
tomorrow morning and continue with
closing arguments at that time anything
from the state
nothing from the state except I was
informed
um that this coffin situation that Mr
Goff was talking about did not have the
defendant's names on them they actually
had the names of Mr Arbury and I think
George Floyd on them so for the purposes
of the record I and I didn't see this
personally I was informed by my people
that it was misrepresented of what names
were on these coffins that were being
shown outside as if it was somehow the
defendant's names and that's not the
case is what I've been informed Plus for
the record
um and I I didn't ask the Sheriff if
that was the case I haven't seen them
and so I'm only relying on what I'm
being told so I wasn't going to spend a
lot of time on the record but that's
consistent with what I was told again I
didn't see them there's nothing before
the court I'm just facing this on
representations made by Council and what
I've been told by the sheriff's
department in addition I only have one
other issue that I think needs to be
taken up a sidebar
um if we could approach about that at
some point
is it substantive Logistics because with
a defendants is it something I need the
defendant's present for why don't you
talk to council before we do it yes I
can talk to Mr Goff about that okay oh
and Council about that okay when we when
we break then let's hold the defendants
and collect Council
Square needs to be discussed
that's one last thing when their jurors
are leaving today if there is this
commotion I expect you've got this all
covered but
there's a plan in place so that um
uh to my satisfaction I don't believe
there will be any issues okay and so
that you and I are using the same idea
when we talk about issues I surely that
I understand that their safety would be
productive will they actually be aware
however of what's been going on as they
leave how could they not let's go ahead
and talk about this
all right great thank you John
on that note your honor
the issue that we have is making sure
that your record is clear
that they have heard or haven't that's
number one number two that they don't
feel like or are made to feel like
they're in danger by ushering them into
internal rooms which I understand is
necessary but I worry that the act of
doing so creates an issue
maybe that's not to be honest a little
bit more than so when I walked in I
could hear
some noise outside it's muffled you
can't really hear it but I was listening
for it because it was the first time
I've been in that room during really the
proceedings okay I heard something and
did in fact say oh have y'all been
hearing this and the response was oh we
just heard that
that's it
so no and it's muffled you can't
actually hear what it is you just hear
there's a commotion what I heard was
just it apparently right as I went into
the room the a group went around the
side of the building so it was on my
radar and just for the record heard it
and um
no it it is not
it is not I understand the concern and I
understanding where we are with the case
I thought I'd put it on the record
simply to say here's what we're doing
but no they're not being moved because
there's a commotion outside they're
being moved because I thought they
simply upon that and me hearing that it
was in the best interest of the court to
go ahead and put them into one of the
courtrooms Interior thank you also if
the court could put in place something
to prevent during deliberation people
walking around the courthouse
it's not a necessary feature of the
first amendment that they walk on all
four sides of the courthouse to make in
our first amendment speech heard and
known if we could keep them on the front
if the court could do that with the
sheriff's department we would ask that
you do that we we just think this is a
Tipping Point issue for the jury if
there's any chance of them hearing that
or seeing that I'll think that through
um candidly Mike
Dives and concerns about doing that only
the any action of the court or the
sheriff's department generally has met
with a some type of reaction
and I don't want to
I don't want to do that I don't want to
create problems where there aren't any
it's just a matter of this afternoon
there's a group that walked around the
courthouse and I could hear it that's
one thing
um if it is something different or it
becomes much more significant then I
need to figure out how to address that
and make sure that there isn't an issue
with the jury I'll go ahead
go ahead understand the concern though
uh I think I've
walked worked through the McMichaels and
Mr fried
no you are okay all right I'm going to
bring the panel in I'll dismiss them for
the day and then I'll step down if
Council discuss whatever you need to
discuss and then let me know if there is
something we need to do on the record
before the defendants if not
sounds like I probably need to meet with
you on the back anyway based on
questions that were asked by Miss hope
okay all right let's get the panel why
do I get the sense that this judge is
um
what's the word I'm looking for
sort of
neutrally concerned with following the
proper procedure
above
sort of Optics and
personal I I don't know I don't even
know like yes a normal judge why do I
get the feeling that this is a normal
judge
I want to say thanks to King makien for
subscribing via twitch putting us at 94.
it's so great to be back on Twitch out
of twitch prison
um and it's fantastic to be back I
appreciate everybody who's been dropping
in really dumping in twitch
subscriptions also want to remind you
guys we have a new coupon code that
coupon code is Obama Obama and you can
use that code to save 68 on my website
joinpakman.com I would love for you to
grab a membership it's the best way to
support what we do uh you of course as a
member will get priority handling on our
upcoming viewer town hall on December
14th and lots of other really really
great things so please consider
yourselves invited
and consider it a public service
to sign up at joinpakman.com
oh thanks also to chat Iraq for the
twitch Prime subscription very much
appreciate that
I do not have any hot tub stream to
announce at this time
at this time is the key phrase
but it's safe
all right ladies and gentlemen we're
gonna go ahead and break for the day
so uh we're gonna start a little bit
earlier tomorrow we're going to start at
8 30. so we're going to uh get into the
states closing at 8 30. uh during the
recess again
do not discuss this case amongst
yourselves or with anybody else don't go
looking for any information about the
case if anybody approaches you about the
case please let the court know we'll go
ahead and get that addressed don't go
looking for any information in the news
don't look at social media
and again if you're in the presence of
anybody that wants to talk about the
case you need to walk away and you need
to let the court know if that has
occurred pizza is here again I want to
thank you for your service you've heard
me say it over and over again and you're
probably getting tired of it but it is
greatly appreciated by the superior
court of Glenn County
have a good evening and we'll see you
back here at 8 30 in the morning
all right for the jury
so the jury now being excused I want to
say thanks to M Geeson Freddy Bob and
snappy Tam for the twitch Prime
subscriptions thanks guys really
appreciate that very very much they will
be starting early tomorrow I always
wonder like what percentage of the
jurors are looking at social media and
coverage of the case it just seems so
hard to imagine that they're really
following that not saying people are
dishonest I just don't know how you
avoid it
how do you avoid it
anything further from the state four
recess no just the um
and just I think we're going to need to
inquire of them in the morning I think
it's imperative I sense that my feeling
is that this is a moment in this case
I'm concerned about our jurors I know
they're tired I'm seeing some
frustration I'm seeing some head shaking
and I'm worried and I'm going to ask the
court to inquire of them in the morning
on the record with US president
yes it was indicated where we are in
case from Greg with Michael
sorry 219 the videos that were discussed
in the last week of jerseys
of filing because it leads to
be accuracy
I'm happy to do it however
yes I'm happy to do it however before it
tells me to do it so let's um
let's do I need to do a ceiling order
for it or
yeah I I we just need the ceiling order
for those are the tickets all right guys
they're just wrapping up here with some
technical stuff so we'll pick it back up
tomorrow then the charges will actually
be be read to the
um uh jurors and then they will be often
negotiating and there is the desire I
know that there's the desire for this by
some to be done before Thanksgiving so
we could get a quick verdict we just
don't know so we'll pick it back up
tomorrow I will see everybody then thank
you for joining me great to be back on
Twitch
foreign